what's going on everybody my guest today
is Big Mel Chancey I can't say enough
good about Mel he's one of these guys
that just carries this light around with
him makes everybody around him happy Mel
is a former president of the Hells Angel
biker gang he ran the Hells Angels in
Chicago during their Infamous War With
The Outlaws we're going to talk about
the fact that Mel had to live most of
his life with the Target on his back and
what that meant about the life that Mel
LED in Chicago what led him into the
biker gang his time in prison what he
learned from it we're going to talk
about Mel's relationship and God and his
faith and then we're going to talk about
the project that Mel and I are doing
together with my dear friend Dwayne
Johnson I'm super proud of this
conversation I love Mel and I'm just
enormously grateful that he came on
melchancy is most definitely a real one
thanks for listening guys
[Music]
thank you
Mel uh did you meet everybody everybody
met everybody yeah I did hey so [__]
Mel chancy Mel chancy you know I I I
think uh
now since since um you could you can you
could ask any of these guys in this real
ones team you know since this thing
started
um I don't think there's been anybody
I've talked about as much as as much as
you who I think you know just really
embodies the the the spirit and and the
ethos of of
um in whatever message we're we're
really trying to bring uh yeah I I have
to say in full disclosure before we talk
I just gotta say brother I love you man
I love you I love you so much it's such
a uh a gift to me and my family and in
my life uh you inspire me so much
um I never met somebody who uh carry so
much light you always make me happy
every time I get a call from you uh I I
I I feel Joy and and
um I feel inspired and and uh you remind
me always about what's important in life
and um I just I'm I'm a richer man for
it and I I cherish this relationship I
I'm just a normally enormously uh just
just just grateful man that you're
hearing that you're in my life yeah um
and I think you know man in in spending
this time with you you know another
thing that that we've discussed and that
comes up on this show over and over
again is uh you know man you're also
you're also somebody uh day
when you talk to anybody uh in the law
enforcement community and and the one
percent community and the Motorcycle
Club Community and the criminal
Community yeah there's also probably
nobody that says respected or or feared
as as the man that you were and um both
of these things are true I talk to
people who talk about your light talk
about your ability to inspire talk about
your ability to uplift and then you talk
to to folks like like the main man Lou
who's here with us today who's also a
real ones get a guest George Christie
Nick anybody you know who talks about
you yeah um you know you really were the
real deal and it's something that we've
we've talked about a lot but that only
folks that have really been in that
Valley can really get to that
Mountaintop and and uh you know you are
you are that guy and
um you know that's uh that's something I
really want to just kind of explore
today and and talk about you know and um
the past is the journey where I'm at now
right I mean you know I became that guy
that I probably should have never you
know been in that lifestyle to start
with but I was I like you know I took a
look down that street and decided I
wanted to run in there you know God
protected me for the season I was there
and uh and that brought me to where I'm
at right so you know as we always talk
about sometimes you know the the past
and the mistakes that I have made and
the the man that I was back then
obviously is is cultivated to where I'm
at now in the gratefulness I have and
everything so it's you know it's always
a blessing for me too so so just tell me
like like off the bat now like how would
you if somebody if somebody would say
hey man who's Mel chancy like how would
you describe yourself like how would you
describe yourself for somebody who
didn't know you've never met you before
um you know I would say that I'm a a
humble
boy as I still call myself right uh my
my daughter who is Now 37 and I have a
16 year old grandbaby and an
eight-year-old grandbaby well my
daughter nicknamed me Peter Pan back in
the day when she was young right and
she's like Dad you're never going to
grow up you always got the Lost Boys
around you you know the Peter Pan story
you know and uh so the same thing I'm a
grateful humble guy that was saved by
grace you know I made some bad decisions
and I didn't come from a family like
that I came from a strict Catholic
Family my two older sisters went to
Catholic school you know I was an altar
boy I was the president of the student
council I was that guy right and I met
them the motorcycle dudes when I was
young you know 15 and 16 years old in a
gym there was a gym in my neighborhood
and you paid uh ten dollars I believe
and you got a key and it was it was the
size of your gym in the garage right and
just the key you can go anytime
I was in there as a youngster I've Loved
bodybuilding flipping the magazines and
seeing you know the greats the Lee Haney
and the Lee libratos and um I love the
bodybuilding and there was these three
dudes in there that were training in
jeans
no shirts concrete guys and stuff and
they showed me how to train like Hey kid
that ain't right do this do that and
they showed me the old school way of
training lo and behold they were members
of the hell's henchmen which we were
before we we patched over to Hell's
Angels in Chicago and and I didn't know
that for you know maybe you know close
to you know eight months a year later I
didn't know because they came in their
vehicles or if they came on their bikes
they didn't you know they were training
so they didn't have their patch on
so it's funny story I say the same guys
that showed me how to train the old
school way and you know get bodybuilding
big
um showed me how to
live the motorcycle lifestyle right the
one percenter lifestyle and and at that
point like what what kind like how would
you describe yourself with that like a
kid going into that gym what kind of kid
were you
you know bright-eyed bushy-tailed eager
to learn I loved I wanted to be He-Man
was uh uh the He-man you know cartoon
figure was my you know I had the blonde
hair and I was like man I love this you
know and I said you know I was inspired
by that so I wanted to you know take my
body to that level I wanted to be big
and and not I didn't know I was ever
going to become what I became right I
always wanted to get big in the
bodybuilding world because I loved it I
love training my body I loved watching
it grow I loved the discipline and took
to eat and everything that these guys
showed me and I say a funny story is
they all wear jeans you know most most
biker dudes ain't training legs you know
but
to be a bodybuilder and stuff and to be
up on them stages like I wanted to do
when I was younger you know in training
legs I train legs and stuff you know and
I was able to grow and stuff so I was
bright-eyed right to learn from these
from these cats and then you know as I
found out who they were and then I seen
wow these guys are I like this part you
know and what did you like about it uh
you know the camaraderie I seen I like
bikes I grew up with some dirt bikes and
stuff like that I like them Harleys and
then the camaraderie and the Brotherhood
that I seen and then they took me down
to the clubhouse and you know I'm 17 18
years old and you know and uh you know
I've started to see what was going on
there and but I mean that's not normal
right I mean like what was it what was
it about you that they saw at 17 years
old to take you down to the clubhouse
um you know I think that it was just
that I was
eager I listened to them I watch them
like I got I got kicked out of school uh
before I was 16. I I sacked the
principal I was getting I was getting
thrown out there was a fight in school
with some with some different
neighborhood people right and me being
one of them we got into a fight in there
and I was in the principal's office you
know he was in the in the other uh he
was in his office I was in the waiting
room with and he was with my mom my mom
an old Italian lady right uh and uh you
know raises our family we're very
close-knit family so when they got me in
the office and stuff he had you know
this attitude and he told my mom you
know you know we're suspending them you
know I wish these parents here knew how
to raise their kids and you know my mom
was just you know listening to him and
stuff and kind of was mad at me that I
was getting in a fight in school and
stuff and I just seen the way he was
talking and you know I didn't like the
disrespect that he had and I jumped over
to desk and socked them in the nose
right and uh then I had to hightail it
out of there and run through the
neighborhoods and try to get back to my
family's home where I lived but by the
time it took me 20 minutes and by the
time I got there the cops were they're
waiting for me so we went back there and
everything and uh
um you know no charges pressed and my
mom signed me out I said I want to go to
school no more and she said okay so she
had to sign me out I wasn't 16 so she
signed me out and I jumped in the Family
Pool we had and just started lounging
around in the Sun and about a week later
she came with some construction boots
and she said hair and I go what's up for
mine she goes you're going to work
you're not going to lay around this
house yeah and my uncle had owned a
concrete company at the time and that's
what them cats were doing that showed me
the gym stuff they poured concrete oh
wow lo and behold here I go to work with
my uncle and the concrete crew you know
and I stayed there for about a year me
and my uncle were bumping heads because
I was his nephew so we expected way more
out of me and then we just and I went to
work with with one of them guys on the
crew and that's when I started doing
pouring concrete so now I was with one
of the guys every day his name was John
I was with him every day pouring
concrete didn't go on a train and going
down to the clubhouse well
he tells me when I get down there he
goes hey man I know you're uh 18 you
look 30. you got to be 21 to get in the
club tell these guys you're 21 and I'm
like okay all right sounds good right so
I get down there one night and they're
all having a meeting and stuff and I'm
upstairs the meeting was downstairs they
called me down in the room and then I
said all right Mel you uh you want to
come around and hang around the club I
said I do and the president at the time
says well how old are you and I looked
around the room and man I just got that
you know my nuts came up in my stomach
and I was like man 18. and they all
looked around and they look they looked
over there at another member who was you
know grooming me too this guy Big Al
he's he's on my arm right here he got
killed and
um they looked at him and I go no no
it's not his fault I said I told these
guys I was 21 because I'm in the bars
and everything like that I said so I'm I
apologize here you know and they're like
well you can't come in the club tier 20
when I said I get it but I'll just
continue to hang around and everything
like that so then I took a little Hiatus
for about a year I was just pouring
concrete with them and stuff and you
know I I had my daughter at 17 so my
daughter was very young you know I was
with her mother since I was like I think
like 15.
I was concentrating on that well now I'm
about a year later so I was like 19 now
and I went down for a party and then
seen me in a year or so and they're like
hey how you been on the I'm good you
know well how old are you now I said
it's only been a year and some change
I'm 19 and they said man you're gonna
age rough you look older you want to
come in the club I said I do they said
okay come on let's make it official you
become an official hangaround yeah
Prospect and then you get voted right
yeah so that's how it happened and
that's what I did and I was very eager
there you know when I got into that
world I wanted to learn that world you
know who knew that world you know what I
mean in in that and what I mean about
that world you know when the when the
motorcycle club started you know back in
the 40s and 50s and stuff like that was
at Brotherhood right guys coming home
from the service the Vietnam stuff and
the Brotherhood of everything uh the
history of the Hell's Angels and
everything like that and that
Brotherhood that camaraderie is
something that you know so dear to
myself you you know you know how we feel
um so I love that I love to see that you
know and that's what I was doing we were
spending time with each other at homes
and Christmases and Thanksgiving and
Godfather to each other's kids and stuff
like that
but in that world comes the nonsense the
violence the Tit for Tat with the other
clubs and stuff like that as we say you
know and uh you know and I was into that
part you know them cats showed me the
violent side of of the the lifestyle and
as I say I got bit by that
it it just trapped me and I I got sucked
into it like a shark in the water and I
tasted that that violence and that power
and that
it's our way or no way kind of mentality
and stuff and uh I I grew into that
right and uh it's like I always said you
know different seasons in my life you
know is uh and uh and and that's how
that Journey started you know what what
was your like history with violence at
that point like you know I mean you said
you I mean most people there's people I
got in trouble at school all the time
ain't a [__] chance I'm punching the
principal in the face you know what I
mean yeah but they're like like clearly
you know you're you're built different
you know that like I said there's one
percenters there's there's got and then
there's you right there's a different
there's a yeah sort of a different level
what was your history with it before
what what was it that you were so kind
of for lack of a better word good at
being by yeah zero history right I grew
up with a loving mother and father my
two sisters babied me I'm the only boy
in an Italian family so you know I was
catered to hence why I went with so many
different women in my life because the
women Kai used to tell my mom you did
this to me you made it you spoiled me
and now I need all this right so I had
no oh you know I'm a little fight in
schools and you know the playground
stuff right no history of the violence
but you know I I learned it fast and I
watched it and I watched how some of
these guys came right in and when it was
time to fight and throw hands
there was no question about it you
weren't you know or Chicago it's the
South Side the city of Chicago back in
the 89 90 91 era and it you just weren't
it was a sock and the guy's down on the
ground you were making sure that dude
from that other club did not get up to
hurt any of the team that we were with
you know so I learned that and there's a
currency to it right I mean like what
what do you think that is you know there
there's something about with men that
that you know I just know even like with
the guys I grew up with my best friends
it's
there's strangely you know when you're a
young man there's not that many ways
especially back in the day to be able to
tell your best friends tell the people
that you cared about the most that you
love them and one way to do that is to
get their back and one way to do that is
is is through violence I think a lot of
mistakes are made a lot of bad choices
are made because of that can you talk a
little bit about the currency of
violence and how being violent kind of
connected you with these guys and what
they saw on you and can you talk about
maybe your first first sort of
opportunity to do that yeah or one that
you remember sure so we were we were at
odds with another motorcycle club in the
city and uh and it was it was before the
outlaw it was this award started and the
Skirmish started you know and um you
know as I said before you know it was
like playground stuff but it was beating
with you know baseball bats ballpeen
hammers going into bars looking for
these guys I'm coming in looking for us
that type of violence we used to call
them the Hunts right and you know all
right let's go out tonight and do a hunt
and see who's out and you know we were
you know having that that
um turmoil with that other club you know
and I was out every night that I could
be out with the guys you know when I was
a prospect for the for the henchmen at
the time I was staying out till four or
five o'clock in the morning going home
packing my lunch and getting on a
construction site at 7 in the morning
right the whole time I was prospected
you know that's the life I was living
and uh you know I didn't I was working
the normal job it wasn't until later I
and when I seen the game of how I could
make some money without working you know
that I became in that but uh that's what
I was doing I was going to work being
that guy all through the the late night
hours and then going on and pouring
concrete all day and then as soon as I
was done I would go to the gym and train
because that was my passion right I did
not miss days at the gym I love the gym
I wanted to train I loved the feeling of
it and then I'd go home and get a little
sleep in maybe 10 10 30 at night time
the witching hour we would say hey we
get a call or get a page back in the day
right the pagers and let's go there's a
few guys here there's a few guys here
let's go you know I still lived with
my ex Jenny and my daughter Danielle we
had an apartment right and you know I
was so as you know how much of a family
man I am I I was I had a shelter that I
could not bring them into this world I
could not do it the the girl that I was
with Jenny that I you know was with for
years she didn't understand that world
nor I didn't want her to so I sheltered
them I kept everything away from them
because I didn't know what where it was
going to take us with all this right so
it was a balancing match for me you know
and I learned that young you know and it
kind of groomed me before the big events
came with you know with the Hell's
Angels and the Outlaws in the midwest
there which which got very serious right
so
um I guess I was getting my PhD in all
that on the job training you know so was
there anything was there any sort of
thing I mean your prospect and was there
anything that went down that like really
what was the first thing that that kind
of caught the attention of these older
guys I mean I I don't know where you
whether you're trying to fit in with
them where you're trying to impress them
we're trying to show love to them show
Fidelity and loyalty to them was there
was there one event was there one thing
where they said okay this guy he's he's
he's down for it or was it just just
Jeremy like that yeah no I think there
were the first incident that I that I
remember you know just starting it off
or where they seen me you know is when I
we walked into a bar I think there was
about five or six of us and uh there was
about a dozen of of the other club guys
in there this is before the Outlaws
though and uh and it was on right and we
were outnumbered and I was happening to
be outside and I came running in and got
right in the mix of stuff and you know a
lot of guys on top of us I remember at
one point I was on the ground and I had
a a bar stool and I was holding on to it
over my head so they weren't kicking me
in the head at least because they were
getting rib shots in yeah and we were
just all jamming you know and the guys
seen that and seeing that was right
there and wasn't running because the
odds were different you know it's easy
to uh when the odds are in your favor
it's easy to stand there but when
they're not you know it takes somebody
that's gonna say hey I got your back no
matter what and I was that and I was
eager and I looked up to these guys and
they became family yeah and and that's
how it started and you know that little
Skirmish that I talk about you know I
guess was grooming me for the next level
that nobody was ready for I don't think
anybody I'm not seeing anybody this is
all different people in life right as we
know bro but you know you're coming into
a motorcycle club you love the
Brotherhood the camaraderie I don't
think everybody anybody woke up in the
morning said I can't wait to blow this
building up today or I can't wait to
shoot this dude off the motorcycle on
the highway I mean there's a few people
that probably enjoy that but for the
most part it just kind of comes with the
territory and you have to be you know I
I would have never thought I'd be in
that position at that young age if you
would have told me a 16 hey in 10 more
years you're going to be in the middle
of something that's going to be on the
ganglands I would have been like what
are you talking about you know none of
us were even on that page right so you
know kind of groomed in there there
naturally so to say and are there guys
you know they're guys that that you
think I mean you you've seen guys that
are just sort of there for for the
Brotherhood and the Fidel that they they
want to wear the jacket they want to
like hang out they want to be in the
clubhouse but they're they're not the
guy who's got to run in when when you're
being outnumbered you come across those
guys as well yeah yeah so so you're
showing that you're not that guy right
right yeah because it seems like you
know and look man I know I know so much
about your story we're friends you know
so like I've heard a lot of these
stories but one sort of recurring theme
with you just always seems It's always
somebody did something that you felt was
unjust somebody hurt somebody that you
love somebody put their hands on a woman
and so you go and you react right yeah
what what was um I mean this club now is
starting to become your family was there
like one inciting incident that then
ratcheted it up to to another level yeah
and and that became so we so in 1994 we
switched from we switched from the
hell's henchmen to how we became Hell's
Angels right we were talking to to the
Hell's Angels and one of the henchmen
was in was in the penitentiary with an
angel out of Minnesota and we he they
had a good relationship with each other
and the Hell's Angels at the time were
never in the midwest it was Minnesota
and then you know uh nothing in the
Midwest and then it was Ohio so there
was that big gap of no Hell's Angels
right there you know and we were the
opportunity right the hell's henchmen
you know three chapters guys that were
you know about it and stuff like that so
once we decided that we were going to
become Hell's Angels well that changed
the game in the history of Chicago
because the Outlaws that was their
Hometown that was their their their
their chapter that the Chicago chapter
was you know on the map how does that
decision give me
um all of us took it to a vote there was
some older guys in the club that were
hell's henchmen at the time that you
know knew that they didn't want to take
that next step and we couldn't blame
them you know at the time I was you know
22 23 years old and these guys were you
know 40s and 50s and they're thinking
okay once we make this decision to
become Hell's Angels it's it's going to
turn the city upside down here the
Outlaws are not going to be happy with
this and you know we don't know what's
coming but we knew they weren't going to
be happy so some guy split we gave them
the opportunity we said you can't keep
the club the hell's henchmen has to fold
and come Hell's Angels you can't keep
the club you know so guys left the guys
that stayed made the decision to stay
and we kind of buckled up for the ride
because the Outlaws told us there's
nothing more for us to talk about it's
on you know mortal enemies at the time
how did they send you that message we
were we sat with him at a table they had
called you know the the at the time that
the president was a guy that was the
hell's Henson president for probably 15
years
and uh they hit him up and five of us
went to meet five of them at a
restaurant and they asked if the rumor
was true and we said yeah we're doing it
we're we're going to become Hell's
Angels and uh they said okay there's
nothing more for us to talk about see
you when we see you and I knew right
then and there at when them cats left
that table it was going to get serious
so what and then what is that so what's
like once you leave that table what's
the conversation like what what does
that for you like is there any part of
your like [__] it's it's it's on now or
you like bring whatever comes and I'm
super young at the time and these cats
are you know 10 12 15 years older than
me that just you know on the outlaw side
too and serious cats right we The
Outlaws had a very very
tough reputation these guys weren't uh
pushovers by any means you know they had
a very hardcore crew in in these five
cats that came from their team were the
hardcore dudes and I looked in and
looked in their eyes and seen it you
know and uh when we were leaving and I
said well we we kind of knew the outcome
we were gonna get yeah we knew nothing
was going to happen at the time we were
in a restaurant we picked you know we
all picked a restaurant where it was you
know neutral and uh we were just you
know going home saying well boys no we
got to see what's going to happen here
you know we didn't we weren't taking
anything to them they were not happy
with what we were doing so we were kind
of like sitting back and seeing how it
was going to go and things escalated
very fast very fast
um
um the beating started the bar room
stuff catching a couple guys in the bars
they jumped a few of our guys we
returned the favor and it started that
way and um and then it's like they took
a step up with the violence and we had
to try to take the step up to do it
right there's no Playbook right it's not
your reading from it's like you have to
be Johnny on the spot and come you know
take what comes your way and that's how
we were all doing it right none of us
really knew anything I mean when they
put the bomb on our clubhouse in 1994
that was the third largest bomb
to this day it was like the Oklahoma
McVeigh it was um uh the trades Towers
you know in New York and this was the
third largest bomb detonated in the
United States to this day and uh was you
know we didn't know about bombs I could
barely put the battery in my pager
you know we did I didn't put you know I
was I did with motorcycles I put the gas
in how did that go how did the bomb go
to did the bomb what happened what was
the story with that so there they um put
a hundred pounds of C4 in a car
shaped it and everything like that
drove it up our clubhouse was on a in a
crazy it was called Grand Avenue and it
was a very busy street and it was about
five o'clock you know in a weekday
afternoon it was a Tuesday Wednesday or
something like that middle of the week
traffic going by and everything and uh
they
built they built the bomb in the trunk
of this car and one of their members who
you know got ricoed and went to prison
it's all you know this is God Gangland
stuff and every you know knowledgeable
he drove the car
in in Black the front door of the
clubhouse because they thought people
were in the clubhouse because there was
some cars out in front there was a
member from Minnesota with his girl
visiting but they were sightseeing at
the time
and that thing he got out of the car the
car picked them up you see from the
cameras and he barely got out of view of
the cameras you know block or so away
and that thing detonated and by the
grace of God
two minutes before that a city bus went
by filled with people CTA bus you see a
cop car goes by real slow and the cop
looks at the door and he goes well it's
probably the Angels you know we were
that neighborhood the henchmen been
there since the 60s
oh that's probably the Angels doing
moving something I mean if he would have
stopped and got out nobody would have
lived through this so that bomb goes off
you know it blasts down and it blew up
five six seven foot hole in the ground
they found the VIN number a mile away
right when the ATF gets in there and
does you know does their investigation
hits the front door big steel front door
blows it out of the back of the of the
building through it you know a big
building you know Old Chicago building
three levels the blast goes across the
street there's a house that's siding
like aluminum siding house by the grace
of God nobody's in the house it just
rips the house apart
nobody gets hurt knocks all the lights
out on on off or for blocks around I
mean just turmoil right so I was sitting
at home and I get a phone call and from
one of my friends and he goes hey bro I
I think your Clubhouse is on the news
and I go well he goes turn on the news I
go what channel he goes any of them and
I turn on the news and I look and I'm
just seeing the city the the block but
with no lights
the car pieces fi infernos on the
streets and I think we've seen it in the
sizzle reel of that you know where the
the guy was out there from the news and
stuff like that and I said yeah that's
our clubhouse you know so we all got it
got on the phone with each other and we
met a few blocks away there was a gas
station
and we came down to the gas station and
stuff and it was just it was so crowded
it was like if you were there signing
autographs the place was just jammed
with people because they had everything
shut off nobody could get Merit right so
we were all in a gas station we're like
man what happened here right and the
neighbors are like man an explosion went
off on Grand Avenue right and we're like
okay so um as I'm standing there talking
to the fellas I hear my name get called
hey Mel and I look around and it's it's
a couple ATF guys a couple guys that I
already knew who they were
and they said hey man come here we want
to talk to you I said okay they go uh
what's going on here I go I have no idea
man I just seen it on the news you know
they said well who you thinking I go I
don't have no idea your guess is as good
as mine right you knew exactly I kind of
figured it was um so we didn't have
anybody that you know that was could do
that at that capacity that we knew
besides some guys
so I see he goes it's a mess down there
man he goes it's it's a disaster I said
anybody heard he goes no nobody hurt
nobody was in the building I find out
later from you know from Lou and the ATF
guys you know it would have blast like
that if anybody was in that building it
would have just ripped their air drums
out they would have been bleeding
internally just from the concussion
right not the blast the concussion and
stuff like that and I said okay cool I
said uh can I see the place and he says
yeah if you talk to me I said yeah let's
go let's walk and talk you know how we
think it was the Outlaws I go well guys
I don't know I was at home I wasn't here
when somebody you know did this right
and I seen the building I seen the
street and I was like look like Beirut
when I used to watch the old because at
this point you're not interested you're
only interested at one kind of Justice
at this like you know exactly what
you're like yes yeah yeah what's that
feeling yeah that feeling was like like
so when I got back after seeing the
building and the in the and the FED said
okay we're seizing this now this is ours
we're having people flying from
Washington this is a big deal it's we'll
let you know when what's gonna happen
but we were taking over this this this
property right and I said okay you know
they we're out there and the guys we had
guys it was our job as members to make
sure we were watching the building too
because they cleared the street up Grand
Avenue opened and we had guys that had
to sit out there in shifts 10 hour
shifts and stuff to make sure because
there was gaping holes in this building
but every day people were flying in from
Washington and you know going through
the place and making sure you know they
wanted to you know do all their
investigation and stuff
and at the time you know funny old
saying is I used to say man tie your
shoes up boys it's getting it's going to
get crazy here right and uh you know we
were doing that tit-for-tat thing you
know and like I said none of us knew
that game so it became from
it was a personal level fighting running
in each other's bars doing stuff like
that you know to now wow this thing just
happened and turned the game around with
the bombing stuff right and that was the
first of a few that happened you know
then you know as you know they started
doing it to the vehicles
and we had no idea you know we all had
remote starts because after this bombing
we were like okay man we got to check
our houses check our cars I had a
Corvette at the time remote starting it
and stuff
in one of our one of the Hell's Angels
from Rockford
I had a pickup truck and he had a remote
start on it he started it and everything
was good and he got in a truck and he
put it in reverse well they had tied
they set the device up and they tied
something to the Yoke of the trans so in
the trans spun it detonated that thing
and it blew him up in the vehicle
Blake's pumping blood rip veins hanging
out he died once or twice on the way to
the hospital he revived them and brought
him back he lived but he went through a
horrible process of that he blew you
know blowing him up we had no clue like
man these guys are you know using bombs
and we got remote starts and you know we
we don't know how to do that so we had
to figure out a way to do that and to
get back you know it was you know it was
a way that we had to get back into that
scene we didn't know we were still
trying to run in the bars and find them
as they were finding us and doing the
old hand-to-hand stuff right so we
learned that right and uh then you know
they're put a bomb on their Clubhouse in
the city
after them bombing started so is let me
go back a little bit
after the the truck with Roger then they
put another bomb on a members from
Rockford's truck he found it he's seen
it under there he went under there with
the with the mirror and he's seen the
the bomb
he calls the police the police call in
the ATF the bomb squad they couldn't
detonate it so they built a uh you know
all their stuff around it you know their
wall around it and everything and shot
it with a water cannon and had to blow
the truck up because they couldn't
undetonate the bomb so they've you know
built around and stuff and um so you
know like we've seen in with Bayless
talking you got aubamines and stuff but
when you have two bombings on one day
that's something that they've never seen
before
and then after you know we did their
Clubhouse then that was the full cork
press that's when the government came in
and said hey no more of this like the
violence on violence biker violence on
biker violence they don't like but it's
it's it's passable but when you start
Beirut in the city they're going to come
with the full court press right and uh
and at the time Janet Reno was the U.S
attorney general the United States
Attorney General and stuff and you know
we all know she was no nonsense and she
put a team and she said
both sides get both sides you know and
that's how the RICO investigation
started so you know that kind of
put the city on edge and stuff you know
but I mean during this time you know
people are getting killed I mean people
are dying and and this will but what and
now I mean the scripture you're the
president of the the club at this point
right yeah and I want to I want to know
about that but but what is what is
living in that environment like like day
to day I mean is it are you just fueled
by anger or is there fear like what's
going what's going through your head and
what and are you seeing it how do you
rally the guys around you and and and do
you realize now you're part of something
that maybe you never wanted to be a part
of or but it's too late like what's the
what's the emotion behind that all of
the emotions that you could think about
from Fear to anger to what's happening
here to you know just getting thrown in
the mix I became the president the the
president that was there for a long time
said listen I'm older things are moving
fast
you're the young guy everybody knows you
from around the different chapters and
stuff like that it's time you know and
he and I said well you're gonna have to
school me here a little bit more you
know show me the ways of how to be you
know run the ship here and he did and uh
and you know of course I jumped right
into it so now I'm the president at the
height of 94 when this saw starts
kicking off and stuff and uh knowing
that we got to keep our guys safe too
you know I show everybody you know I got
the tombstones on my arms from the
brothers that got killed in that war and
you know when you see
a brother that you're tight with and now
he's laying in a casket and I'm watching
his 16 year old daughter before we close
the casket lay herself over the casket
and she's rubbing her father's hair for
the last time boy that hits different
you know I remember standing at the
casket a couple of the the brothers were
with me and we were getting ready to put
his patch over him before we shut the
casket right and his daughter jumped in
there and was doing that saying goodbye
to her dad and I remember the tears
coming from my eyes thinking we did this
this was our decisions that made this
all happen here we're all responsible
for this right and how do you get out of
it though how do you just say time out
into something like that you know them
cats weren't wanting hair time out so
you just have to go with the flow right
and be a part of the environment that
got created around you you know like I
said nobody got up that morning and
planned all this right we were like here
we are we like looking back you know
um so a ton of emotions I mean I
couldn't I couldn't just walk into a gym
and start training without having a team
in there watching them front doors
because guess who the target became me
because they were like okay here's this
young dude out there that's a nuisance
to us we're we're still going in and
getting each other in bars and we had a
young crew and we were jacked up and you
know we we adapted to the violence and
you know they were violent cats
themselves so a lot of emotions you know
and at the same time now I'm not with
Daniel's mother no more because I said
it's time like you guys got to go back
and live with your mother and I can't
have you guys around and you know of
course in that environment you know a
lot of women are around right and I've
had a lot and you know I was with a few
different girls and but I I sheltered
them from it you know my personal life
and the club life had to be very
different a lot of guys don't do it that
way there's a lot of guys in the club
and they their personal life in the club
life coexist they bring their girls
around their wives around and stuff like
that I wasn't that guy I couldn't do it
there was a different I never wanted to
like the girls would say are we gonna go
on your bike tonight no I'm not taking
you on my bike tonight I'm not using you
as a bulletproof vest and
um it's this is my world right I'll take
you tomorrow for ice cream or something
we'll go throw darts somewhere but
tonight you you know you know you're not
getting into this world so in my
personal friends that were trying to
come into the club and I used to tell
them the same for you guys you know what
I mean and they're like well you're
doing it I'm like well you see all the
fun stuff you see when we're out in bars
around our bikes and the chicks and the
the red carpet treatment and all that
but uh you know you ain't experiencing
the you know when when our brother's
daughter is rubbing his hair and stuff
that changed the game right so you know
there's a lot of emotions that I was
going through at that young age
becoming that guy
um and then in the gyms and I have a
security team watching for why I'm
training and stuff like that and you
know then at night time we're running
around doing what we're doing that
the stuff that was everybody was seeing
on TV of of the war and the bombings and
the Hell's Angels and outlaws they were
getting a glimpse of the world they
didn't know right so when I would go
downtown to the big restaurants and
stuff next thing I know people are like
hey Mel how you doing come on in let me
sit you at a table here and I'm like wow
what's going on here you know that that
that that gangster
celebrity figure kind of
created itself on its own right and you
know I was always this type of guy I was
always thank you and please I was raised
by my family like that right so I was
always that that gentleman with manners
and stuff
with the flip side of we had to take
care of business when we had to do it
right so all the you know all the old
friends that you hear and are like man
Mel was holding our kids we would leave
Mel with our kids back in the day
but he had another side to him you know
and that was the way for me to do it
everybody didn't do it that way but I
had to do it that way I couldn't you
know I was like losing me if that makes
sense I was losing Mel my nickname was
Road
and I that Persona was growing on its
own you know what I mean you feel me
there it was like I it wasn't everything
that I was doing but it was you know
that the TV made it kind of glamorous to
people wow I remember one time
I got my house rated one of many and uh
I about two days later I got out in a
pond and I'm in a restaurant and we're
eating and the TV the news comes on and
they're still showing it from two days
later there's my picture on TV and
talking about the Hell's Angel Outlaw
War and the turf that's going on and
everything like that and the people in
the restaurant are looking over at me
and I'm eating and next thing I know
they're coming over hey Mel how you
doing man nice to meet you on these in
these you know these uh uppity downtown
restaurants right and uh what do you
think that is man what do you think that
is like what what do you think that's
about because it's everywhere it's
everywhere yeah I think you know people
didn't really know that world and it
seemed like the Mobsters right the
gangster world you know it's uh you know
it's with John Gotti when he was out and
you know he became That Celebrity figure
right you know and people
they look at that and they say wow this
is something they're not doing or you
know you know wouldn't Venture into it's
like foreign so when they see that it's
you know the gentleman gangster right
everybody loved me as Mel was good guy
man we leave our man he never you never
hear him elsewhere in front of everybody
he's very respectful to my wife it's how
I am now right you know and uh but they
knew what the TV was showing them and
what happened was happening with the
violence so I think people are
enthralled with what they don't
understand and they see it you know I'm
not sure they wanted me to date their
daughters but they were liking me in the
in the public figure and that Persona
grew on its own without me knowing it it
wasn't I was trying to do I wasn't
trying to walk around like um because I
knew that them dudes were trying to
knock my head off my shoulders I head up
every morning I got up and every night I
slept I mean there was nobody probably
had more weapons around him than me I'm
in the shower I was that I was always
used to say I'm not getting hit in the
face with a ball Hammer they're not
walking through the door it ax handles
and hitting me if that's what's coming
up it's going to be a different scenario
right we're gonna go I'm not doing that
you know so
um it just it just in that group from
there John you know during that time was
there anybody like during that during
during the height of that was there
anybody that you looked at over on the
other side that uh that you respected or
that you respected and admired or that
you thought was a good that that you
thought was silent solid yeah and it's
funny because after we put these
differences aside I believe it was 97
and we sat down and uh they had just got
the RICO indictment I think it was the
end of 97 the the feds recode think
about eight or ten Outlaws for all these
predicate acts that was going on Jan
Areno said enough get him they had that
bombing thing the guy that uh did the
bombing they caught him you know he
started talking to the government so
they were putting the pieces of the
puzzle together for the RICO right
um so when we said down with them guys
and uh got to talk to him and I I like
the felt I like the few guys that were
doing the talks for them I knew them
from Chicago I knew who they were they
were older than me they knew who I were
but we never had a chance to meet each
other out before this conflict went on
right and then when we met and sat down
we're all the same people right the love
of the motorcycle stuff the Brotherhood
you know not sure too many of them guys
got up in the morning and said let's go
get this war crazy it just started right
it's just something that happened so I
did get along with them guys from 97
when we started that true thing and I
went to prison very shortly after that
like 98 or the end of 98 or somewhere in
there so I was part of that team that
sat down that let's say let's do this
truce we kind of had some rules for each
other what what we're gonna do let's
practice The Good Neighbor Good Neighbor
policy and it started from there and
then you know I was in contact with them
they were in contact with me hey this
happened in South Bend okay I'm gonna
call myself Ben guys up and make sure
that this ain't happening no more no
staring each other down when we're there
none of that derogatory stuff I would
call them up hey we heard this is going
on no that's not going on so we had that
report
get along with each other great you know
to same kind of cats you know what I
mean so I did I did respect them guys
and as I always tell the story
respectfully on their part some bad cats
right there we weren't that we weren't
the dudes running through Chicago
beating our chest like we're the baddest
cats in the land not at all not at all
you know it we were just trying to um
When in Rome do you know what I mean
that old saying like we didn't know
there wasn't a game plan there wasn't a
book that we opened up and said oh this
is the next step oh wow so they just
shot so and so we're gonna go shoot
their dude you know so um
I did I did respect and there's a lot of
guys that I still talk to from The
Outlaws you know that are still in the
club and out of the club and they know
I'm gone since 2004 a long time
everybody knows my story I don't even
ride a motorcycle no more so they know
I'm exited that lifestyle 100 well you
know one thing I know about you too is
like a lot of this a lot of this
violence
you didn't you didn't pass off to other
people there were times where you could
have done that as the President right
but there's something I mean one thing
that everybody says about you
they talk about discipline they talk
about code and they talk about ethics
and that's always been a truth with you
right like when it came down to do the
violence
you you weren't afraid to do it yourself
you were very comfortable doing it with
yourself but even more so than passing
it on to someone else is that correct
yeah I never wanted to be that kind bro
that was like Hey you know this this is
what we're gonna go do go do it you know
I I wanted to be there this we were a
Brotherhood right so if one hurt we all
hurt if a guy got jumped in a bar on
Monday and he's hurt and you can trust
and believe we're gonna go Rectify that
by Tuesday so that's how we were you
know that's how I was and I stood by
that so
and plus I was young John you know and I
didn't do any drugs back in the day I
took steroids and I drank whiskey
horrible combination
at 24 years old right let's be honest
right what's that can you describe Mel a
24 year old Mel on steroids and whiskey
yeah so you know and in the middle of
this violent conflict right so that just
fueled me you know I'm taking the taking
the gear of the different steroids and
hormones is is as I'm training and
everybody know I mean I trained for two
hours every day that was my zen that was
my way to train it got me out of that
world that got me into myself and you
know disciplined and eaten and
everything so you know and then you know
I'm going out at night time living the
one percenter life drinking some you
know I like the Jack Daniels so you put
the fire water in me and we're in a
situation you know if we're out I was
never the guy that you know you know how
you get some guys that drink and then
they're out in bars and then they want
to just go cause nonsense that wasn't me
at all I got to give I give all the
credit
to my mother and father the way they
raised me through my Lord and Savior but
my mother and father raised me to be
that respectful dude and that's the way
I was I didn't get in nobody else's
business but when I was out and had some
whiskey in me and hormoned up and stuff
if something didn't go right
I was the first one to to be in there
you know I was that aggressor we had
that that mentality and a lot of the
younger guys in the club I think I was
the I was I don't think I was the
youngest guy in the club the youngest
president at that time
um
and we had young guys you know that were
you know gym guys hitting the bags and
stuff there was no MMA back in that day
so we had some Street guys that were you
know tough guys and we
got into the violence you know and said
it's like we tasted that that blood in
that violent way and we got enthralled
with it so you know that's uh that's
what I like to say is
doing the hormones and drinking the
whiskey and 24 years old and I'm I'm the
president of the Chicago crew you know
all that was just fueling the fire and
my day once I was done training at the
gym
and whatever house I bounced around to
because I had a four girls spread out
through different parts of the city that
I had homes with and when the evening
time came that was the time that we
would either you know we're going out to
have some fun but we were always had to
be alert and we were always waiting for
them pagers to go off and say
here's here's some guys here here's some
guys here in a bar you know we were all
and that's drop everything we found some
of those guys let's go get them let's go
get them at any moment at any moment so
you're living like you got four [__]
girlfriends right who do they know about
each other
three of them know about each other one
of them that I was with for about six
seven years at this time yeah didn't
right and and her name was Nancy and
that was my girl at the time of girls
the other three were right was with one
for like four or five years one for two
three years in in one for like two years
but Nancy was the one that I didn't she
just figured I was traveling all over
running the club The Whole Nine Yards
the other three knew about each other
and Nancy and Nancy and I told him I'm
never leaving Nancy right it's like my
you know but I love you girls sure as
weird as it sounds sure no no I get it I
guess all I'm saying is that for for
like any [__] you know you know guy
who works at Best Buy having four
girlfriends would be like enormously
stressful right like that's enough to
like [__] be stressful right but you
also everywhere you just everywhere you
go at that time are you worried about
somebody might shoot you or kill like
you there's definitely a Target on your
back right 100 and at any second you
could get a page that says you've got to
go hurt maim or potentially kill sure
right at any at any point at any time so
so what is like that what is like living
in that and I'm sure I'm sure [__]
the joy and the the the the the uh the
the the the fun and the exuberance that
must be you know level 10 but like what
is the stress like what is like how does
that manifest yeah you know at the time
I did didn't see the stress you and
you're living in it right it was until I
went to prison that first time she'll
get into is when I like look back you
know it's like it's like the old saying
you're so deep in the forest you can't
see the trees yeah that's how it was
with me it just was became a everyday
part of life check your vehicle we're
going to the gym check your vehicle re
you know
um repetitive and stuff like that you
know
stress levels are there but I'm young at
the time right and I'm bouncing around
and I'm coming to California and I'm
going to New York and I'm doing all my
stuff you know and with running you know
being the president I'm out here for
meetings I'm on the East Coast for
meetings and stuff going back home and
knowing that I have I'm taking charge
this is my team here and right and
everybody's relying on me around the
country like to the Midwest now was up
for for grabs now and who's going to be
the winner so in the one percenter world
the spotlight was on Chicago
the spotlight was on me probably their
presidents to I'm sure right from their
own nation and stuff like what's
happening there get this under control
you know and you know that's how it was
all where so I had that and in between I
was you know trying to have a little fun
and hitting the strip clubs and still
doing the Brotherhood stuff on the
motorcycles but it got so kind of crazy
for a while you know one summer we kind
of put the motor laid the motorcycles
down a little bit we'd go on runs into
anniversary parties and different
chapters and stuff but when it came to
bouncing around on motorcycles
you know guys were getting shot off them
not our guys their guys you know they
were on their motorcycles and a couple
other guys got shot off the motorcycles
right so I said boys remember when we
were kids and we hung our 10 speeds up
on in the garage upside down put the
bikes away
it's time to get busy here man and uh
We're Not Gonna We're Not Gonna uh have
the joys of running around here like
this we're in a war you know it's a real
deal man we're closing the caskets here
on Brothers here so you know the stress
level was there but I didn't fully
understand it at the time because I'm
young I don't have a career no more I
don't have a job I'm making illegal
money I don't have to go to work I have
you know the Vets the bikes different
homes the girls everywhere I flew I was
the young guy built halfway halfway okay
looking I would get girls when I went so
it was a continual Loop for me to to do
this to do this constantly you know so
it wasn't until I went to prison and I
got a chance to step out to where I said
to myself but what is going on here what
am I doing you know what you know not
only me what are we all doing you know
and I just that's when I said to myself
I just
not the life that I was living I
couldn't see my mother my mother was
four foot tall Italian lady that you
know we didn't even let her come to see
me in prison for a while because she
couldn't stop crying broke my heart you
know what I mean my daughter was young
my father who was you know my pride and
joy in my life who raised me was my
baseball coach at every time I went to
another level
you know you imagine I see how the way
you are with the boys right with Henry
and Bill and how you are and that's how
my dad was come home from work grab the
balls let's go I'm pitching I'm doing
this you know and they just you know and
listen my mom and dad and my sisters
my family house was the house to go to
with the pool and the barbecue and stuff
they loved the fellas they loved all the
guys in the club my mom get in here eat
I got a whole you know Italian family
get in here and eat and then we'd leave
and we'd put the vest on the patch on
and my mom would have the Rosary in her
hand and just shaking her head like that
she didn't like the club but she liked
the fellas when I was in prison the
fellas are over at the house I'd call
and talk to my mom dad hold on pass the
phone around what are you guys doing uh
mom's feeding us you know I mean you
know so you know going to prison and
seeing that and getting you know if I
didn't go to prison
if I I said that was God's time out for
me like hey man go sit in the corner for
a minute think about what you're doing
and I did and I was like man I can't
can't do this lifestyle no more I can't
do this to my mother and father we
started letting my mom come and see me I
was in a state prison in Illinois so I
was about two hours away
and my mom would come and see me and
she'd cry and I would just hug her you
know and you're not really supposed to
have any contact but the guards is my
mother you know she'd sit next to me and
I'd hug her I'd say a couple years Mom
I'm coming home and I said I'm not I'm
not leaving again I'm staying with you
we're going to raise I'm going to raise
Danielle and be that father and be there
and be a family guy that you guys
instilled in me and uh I can't do this
no more
well the feds indicted me when I was in
the state prison they had they were
holding a charge on me and they indicted
me I had to go give them they gave me
they gave me 18 months I think on it I
did uh 13 or 14 and decided to go right
to a federal prison and when I came home
from that Federal time
2000 and the end of 2000 2001
um I had a thing called non-association
where I couldn't talk to anybody in
clubs if I walked into a bar and they
were there I had to leave I walked in a
grocery store I could not get pictures
with them I had a rough parole officer
and she's like I if I catch you around
one talking to one I'm sending you back
so it was very they're very strict on me
and like you heard from Lou everybody
had a Target on me because now I'm not
ricoed yet I went to prison the first
time on my own stuff on my outside gig
as you you know and uh and then the feds
hit me on this mail fraud thing so they
didn't get me yeah on the RICO like they
wanted to like they you know they got
the Outlaws and stuff and you know I
used to tell that the guys in the club
the Angels like hey man them guys got
ricoed or next don't think they like us
and they don't like just them this is a
joint decision here right they're gonna
build a RICO on us in the predicate
access what we're doing right you know
that's what Rico consists of the
predicate ax you're doing shooting on
the highway blowing up a building
beating in the in the in the bars you
know and um so when I came home I
couldn't be around him I had three years
of non-association and I I went downtown
into the City and I started running
these nightclubs my friend owns with the
security putting the security teams
together and living my life with my
family you know and that's when I made
that decision that's I'm hanging it up
you know I got in the club and
90 let's see 16 17 80 and 89 at 20. and
and got out and and got out and quit in
2004. you know I made that decision and
I told the fellas I can't do it no more
I can't put my mother and father through
this I can't just come back in the club
and be a normal member right now in in
the 2000s after I'm home from prison
this the skirmishes started between the
Outlaws and Angels again it only lasted
a couple years where everybody was cool
and then the ego is getting away and the
territory gets in the way and all that
stuff and and it's who's the big dog on
the black mentality right so as I'm on
non-association little things are
happening The Outlaws are calling me up
and I said I can't get involved in this
uh we can't that President's that's
running it here we can't get along I
said well that's on you guys guys I
can't even take your calls right now so
respectfully I'm I'm not in that
position to make any decisions you know
it was all coming back to me again and
I'm thinking you know in in you know the
guys that I came up with in the club
when they decided they heard that I was
going to quit and they came over and
they're like man you're gonna quit and
I'm like guys I can't do this no more
man I gave as much as I could give of
myself to this club like you said I
wasn't the guy sitting at home petting
the cat when everybody was doing stuff I
was running in the doors first and
foremost when guys were like we got this
and I'm like I'm you got it with me you
know what I mean I'm coming with you so
I told him I can't do that you guys all
love my mother I love my mother I can't
do that to them I'm gonna be the death
of them and I'm gonna hang it up you
know that was my decision to hang it up
I quit the club in 2004 and then a few
months later I got ricoed the rink okay
you know and it was like I was paying
the pendant of my past as I said and I'm
funny I made a promise to my daughter
Daniel
and now she's you know in her you know
14 15 and I said I'm not going back I'm
done I'm going to concentrate on you and
the family and I'm gonna live a a
different life now you know and she said
okay in the morning that
Bayless and the crew but Bayless wasn't
at my house but the morning the ATF SWAT
guys kicked my doors in
it was about 5 30 in the morning I was
it was at one of the girls houses I was
with you know and uh I was having eight
o'clock breakfast with my daughter so my
daughter was at the restaurant
waiting for me and then my mother called
her on the phone and she said I need you
to come over to my house so she went by
her Grandma's house the girl I was with
Kathy was at the house and and my mom
said they came and grabbed your dad this
morning you know they locked them up and
charged them with Rico so my daughter
was upset because I had just promised
her I'm never going back but then when
she learned about it and she said this
is all from the 90s yeah yeah yeah yeah
when I was pleading guilty to the RICO
my last predicate Act was 97 because
then I went away yeah right right right
right right right 2004. I'm pretty and
I'm like okay some you know I'm locked
up and um you know been talking to the
Lord and I said all right Lord
it's got to be something here you know
because I came home and I started
changing my lifestyle I got rid of the
you know the the one percenter stuff and
then me personally selling drugs and up
for the club debt was my gig right it's
how I supported myself
with the with the selling the drugs and
everything and I gave up all that I'm
running nightclubs and I'm you know but
I still wasn't cleansed of everything I
still had that womanizing in me I still
wanted to you know have all you know be
be with multiple girls I still was in
that lifestyle yeah I wasn't shooting
dudes off motorcycles or selling drugs
anymore but I'm thinking all right I'm
not a bad guy right now right but I
still had that that cleansing right and
that's when I sat there and it was um
2005 and um and I was in an eight by ten
by myself you know and I got down on my
knees and I said all right God you got
my full attention
you know I was praying the whole time I
was you know is you always I always say
I want to be that hypocrite so when I
went to the Joint the first time and of
course knowing the Lord and being you
know Catholic and everything
I started praying
start a fellowship when I was reading
the Bible I was getting into the word
you know a lot of guys leave the prison
and they throw the Bible at the front
door to somebody else well that's the
you better take it with you it just
doesn't work for in there now you're
going back into the real world right so
I always said I never want to be that
hypocrite I never want to leave you I
want to fellowship with you and feel
your presence constantly so when I came
home and you know from the first time
I'm praying and I'm listening to him and
I'm talking and you know get get my life
right but there was still some cleansing
that needed to be done because you know
Road was was a fine line between Road
and Mel still and um so you know so I'm
back in there and I said okay you got my
attention here I am I've got down on my
knees I don't know what I'm looking at
20 plus years possibly you know no no
outcome yeah just the doors got kicked
in a few weeks earlier and I said um use
me as your vessel I'm here if if my job
is to go to these penitentiaries and
show somebody a change of life or you
know the the fellowship I have with you
so be it
if I could ask maybe you don't keep me
here forever and I could go home but
it's in your will and that's when that's
where my relationship with the Lord
really got strengthened out and I
wouldn't change that for the world you
know it sucked I had to go to some some
you know hardcore federal penitentiaries
you know nobody knows how to do that
there's no Playbook what's going to
happen in there as me and you talk about
and stuff so you know he protected me
enough through another season and
protected me in there and that's how
that relationship grew and that's how
you know where I'm of course at today
right was there one guy that you really
felt like paved the way for you or like
multiple a little bit like I told you a
story about you know my dear friend at
the time who was the sergeant of arms
for our chapter you know and uh you know
he I always say they're you know without
a pulley there wouldn't have been a road
you know and I mean you can't you're not
it's not a one-man show you know as much
as the like Lou said you could get a
one-man Target right but you don't have
a one-man show when you're doing this
you're not you know you're not uh um
Chuck Norris as we like to say you know
so I respected a lot of guys in the club
you know
um a guy that you interviewed George
Christie right I you know George was in
the club many many years before I was
around right and he had you know a lot
of respect out here you know not only on
the west coast but through a sunny
Barger you know what I mean the guys
like that that were older and paved the
way you know you know as you as as they
say you know I might have been the the
Target in Chicago and the guy that
people respected and feared but there
was many guys like that right I didn't
invent that right I wasn't the guy that
could take any credit for that I was
groomed I watched as you know me now for
some time I pay attention to things a
lot of things talking and actions and
stuff like that so
multiple guys that I respected in the
club that showed me a lot of things you
know in in life and had my back a
hundred percent wasn't the road Mel show
it was we were all together and doing
this you know and and we had that team
and and uh so multiple guys that I
looked up to that you know I I asked for
advice for you know what was going on
and then I had guys telling me hey man
you gotta reel it in a little bit we
know you guys are in the middle of the
Hornet's Nest but man
you're going to end up in the
penitentiary for a long time but what do
you do how do you yeah what's it like to
hear that I mean you yeah I remember
hearing that I remember being on a run
a big run in a couple of these older
Hells Angels were looking at me and
saying hey man we get it you know we we
get that we started a turmoil in Chicago
and you guys are there living it right
it's easy for somebody to come in from a
different chapter and hang out for a day
four or five days but they go home we
don't yeah so you know people are like
how come you didn't bring 50 guys and
and just run around and get the well
because they're gonna leave and we're
still here yeah we gotta we gotta try to
you know do this and slip through the
cracks and do whatever we can do right
and uh like I said you know the mount
laws in the 90s had a real live crew
John you know what I mean we weren't
just rolling in on them guys and they
were going uh they were pulling out and
throwing lead at us when they needed to
and doing what they needed to do right
so you know um and then Heron like you
got to take it easy a little bit how do
you find that balance you can't you know
I mean we're out at strip clubs trying
to have a little fun and be seen and
kind of controlling the territory we're
in and our pagers are going off you know
pay 9-1-1 a couple of the other guys
here they just jumped the guy here and
we gotta get the girls off our lap and
we're gone at the drop of a hat that's
the way that we had to live that life
and if you weren't ready then you know
we've had guys that left the club during
that war they were like you know what
it's a little too much how about guys
joining I mean like who's joining up in
that and how does that like how do you
how do you judge like what what are you
looking for and so yeah not many in in
the
12 13 years I was in the club I
sponsored one dude and I grew up with
him in in the neighborhood in the
suburbs of Chicago our families grew up
around each other and I sponsored him
and uh and he came in through that right
but we didn't have dudes beating our
door down going hey we want to join we
see the news yeah yeah we see what's
going on hey you know so it definitely
takes a different cat to come in and be
like that you know a couple dudes did
come in in Prospect and and get their
patch through that war but not at all
different now on on the outlaw side
because they controlled the city they
were the big dogs in the city the whole
time and now the Hell's Angel name comes
in and now you got two of the
powerhouses in the same blocks right so
they had other support clubs that were
that were loyal to them so when I tell
you that
at the height of this we had 13 guys in
Chicago
they could put a hundred guys together
from Chicago Indiana because we were on
the where we lived they were on the
border of Gary Indiana Joliet which is
the south of the city two chapters in
Chicago in Wisconsin's an hour and a
half away where they got 30 guys just in
Wisconsin they could put a hundred guys
at an event together in 30 minutes well
we for us to get 100 guys we got a call
West Coast east coast and stuff like
that so we were greatly outnumbered when
it came to physical bodies and we had
that to try to overcome that obstacle
how do you deal with that
get them on get them on the sneak right
we weren't going to bike events where we
knew they were going to have a hundred
guys show up at a bike run we couldn't
have that and then we're gonna be in the
middle of a bike run and you see the
stuff that's going on now and the
shootings are happening right there
because
who's going to get hit with a ball being
Hammer who's getting hit with an ax
handle it this stuff was not no more it
was the shootings and the in this stuff
like that so we knew if we went to okay
they're having this McCormick Place
event there's going to be a hundred of
them there we're going to waltz in even
if we put 25 30 guys together it's going
to be on immediately and when the dust
settles the feds are just gonna pick the
debt up and take them to the to the
Morgan they're going to pick up the
living and take them to the penitentiary
so you know we weren't going to them we
didn't have the numbers to do that at
the time so we had to be covert and Tit
for Tat these guys where we can get them
at and what what's the biggest like
what's the biggest misconception what's
the biggest thing that that when you
when you talk to the Layman like the Joe
public eye when they think about the
Outlaw Biker world like what's what what
what's the thing everybody gets wrong
they don't get
um
you know when I tell the old stories and
you know I see my friends now that you
know didn't know me a lot of a lot of
you know I'm in Florida now right for
the last 10 years a lot of people didn't
know that old me right and I'll tell
them stories and stuff like that you
know it's glamorized in in of course the
Brotherhood and that camaraderie it's
like it's like me coming here and John
with you and I know Aaron and her father
and the whole all the angle families the
the hospitality that I've had here since
Wednesday I'm home right yeah yeah I'm
home here with you guys right you guys
are my family right and that's how it is
that is such an amazing feeling and I
would everybody would want that part of
it right but then comes the nonsense
right you know we're a motorcycle club
but where do we draw the line to where
we're becoming a gang kind of in living
that mentality right so I think people
you know
let's go back in the 90s and people were
glamorized by it now I'm not sure I've
been out of that lifestyle for so long
not sure what people think of the
motorcycle world it's much more talked
about there's podcasts just on the one
percenter world right I mean you can you
have guys that are in these clubs and
they have social media and they're
having pictures and stuff like right
like you couldn't hide me back in the
day because I always had this this kind
of hairdo I was longer in the back I
lost some more through the years but I
always had a different you know
hairstyle I was 290 Pounds tatted up I
look different I wear my patch
everywhere I went besides when I was
training you know I'm the training in
normal clothes but if I was at downtown
if I was on a plane if I was at a club I
was out whether we're on our motorcycles
or not I'm having them we wear our patch
everywhere yeah you know
um so you know that's that now it's so
changed I mean guys are showing their
faces we weren't trying to let everybody
know who we were well I remember one
time one of the members called me up he
says hey you you around I said yeah I'm
around what's up he goes come on down to
the clubhouse I want to talk to you I
said okay I get down to the clubhouse
and he goes look at this was left on our
doorstep I opened up the manila envelope
and it was an epic manual that the from
the that the feds had and you seen like
sent you know ATF sensitive and stuff
like that and I start opening it it's
every picture of the Outlaws their
addresses their homes their license
plates
and it was just delivered to our door
holy [__] nobody knew how it got there
so I'm looking at this epic manual am I
calling it right Lou the Epic manual
right okay so I'm I'm seeing all this
and I'm like and the member goes man
a gold mine huh and I go yeah I go but
guess what
they got one too who delivered this to
our door this didn't come from you know
of somebody in the club right we don't
know to this day who did it right but
guess what they got one on us
that's the mystery that'll never be
probably solved I don't know if there
was you know an agent that wanted the
fuel the fire I'm not I don't know so I
can't pass what was it though
but they got one too
but you know we had a an Unwritten rule
back in the day no homes
no families you know that's and that's
what we were
mostly living by it got violated it did
get violated but we were saying like you
know no families I I seen one of them
cats in a restaurant where's my spot my
restaurant where I was in all the time
and when I walked in seeing the patch
and he was with this girl and a kid
and I was with two other guys and the
two other guys looked and and they said
amen they did this to us and I go I get
it man but not happening and I went over
and told him guess what
beat it man you know I see who you're
with and we're going to respect that if
it was you it's on and popping here you
know what I mean we got you
and uh he he he respected that and he
got up and got out of there and I seen
the look in his lady's eyes and and they
respected that so we pretty much kept
that
Unwritten rule
but but it got violated you know they
they jacked up one of our guys girls
you know and that was a kind of like
something that we weren't familiar with
and didn't want to do back right but it
was getting so heated up and and that
tension was so hot and the and the Egos
and the in the in the attitudes and the
and the violence was getting so raged
that it blurred the lines on their side
too right just like I was doing if you
had some of them guys here and
interviewing them it'd probably be the
same kind of interview right that's
right yeah for sure you know so you know
so um
you know we had that on rent roll but
you know them were the times back then
John and so I think where people see all
that stuff and glamorize it now with the
one percenter world and it's just you
can read about it and watch it on the
news and see these cats and the podcast
and everything
I I think that people are just like they
wanna they wanna put that patch on not
knowing what comes with that or not
knowing the history of it or you are
your brother's keeper you're not just
you know Sons of Anarchy kind of like
blurred them lines for this world I like
to say you know because it made it cool
watch Jack's ride around they're killing
ATF agents nothing's ever getting done
right it's not a real world yeah yeah
you know you know like people say ah you
know I did said something they're like
oh this guy took his uh his Persona from
Jax there's no Jacks back in 1990
there's no Sons of Anarchy you know what
I mean like you know we weren't stealing
anything from some TV show it was us you
know so that kind of blurred the lines
where everybody's like let's put that
patch on let's run in this world holy
cow they just killed JoJo man I'm out
and you see that going on right now or
hey guess what ATF I got something to
tell you you know so it's it's different
it changed right sure and and so let's
you know talk about a little bit about
this big big change for you and and and
so the so the first time the the the
first time you ever get locked up it has
nothing to do with the has nothing to do
with the The Outlaw stuff right no can
you can can you walk us through through
that one so
one of the girls that I was with
um
and she you know I was with her for I
think about two years
she just wanted a little more in the
relationship and she knew I couldn't
give it to her I barely had the time I
you know I maybe would see her once a
week once every other week you know it
was like that with most of them you know
I lived with Nancy so I got to see her a
lot more it was my main one my main spot
that I lived in uh but I was traveling
and running a club and you know dodging
the feds and you know a lot going on for
a 24-25 year old guy now right you know
I couldn't give her the time and I told
her I can't do it so I'm very tight with
your mother and father and her family
and I said you just gotta go on your own
way and go find a dude and you know and
me and you are always going to be
friends I told her her name was Kendall
I said we're always going to be friends
you know I said but I can't give you
that time and I loved Kendall that you
know I had my heart was with her you
know so she got a little scoring at me
and stuff her family owned a a big bar a
big you know in our area that was that
everybody hung out with you know until
four o'clock in the morning enjoying
everybody the who's who came in the spot
so she bartended there and you know I'm
coming in with you know not Nancy Joanne
or Tanda I'm coming with randoms now and
she's telling her dad oh I gotta sit and
he's like you knew you know you knew Mel
a long time and this is the way he is
and he's not bringing in here to throw
it in your face but this is where they
hang there you know what I mean so get
over it right
well she she started dating a guy and he
was a street guy you know we were in our
you know 29 28 at the time I'm guessing
and um you know he was a street guy you
know ran around with the little crew and
stuff like that and I didn't know him
from nowhere I'd see him pop in the
Barbie once in a while and somebody her
sister told me that's who Kendall's
dating and he knew seen me and no
problems we never shook hands we never
talked we just you know no big deal and
um
I I would say probably six seven months
or something into the relationship you
know I guess he was you know putting his
hands on him right he was kind of a
jealous guy and and uh you know putting
his hands on her and her sister had come
to me one time and told me that that
this was happening and just kind of find
it hard to believe that she would allow
something like that to happen coming
from the family she did and her stepdad
my friend being a ex-marine and he was
you know his name was George he was
known that he owned this bar and he was
known as a no-nonsense guy so I didn't
think too much of it John you know I was
like ah I said I'm sure it's it's maybe
he just grabbed her or something like
that you know so you know a little bit
more time went by and we're finding all
I was finding out some more stuff and uh
I just happened to be at her family's
house and uh haven't haven't a bite to
eat and um he would go and eat at your
yeah yeah I would go and eat yeah
because I was tight with her mom and you
know her stepdad is her stepdad that had
these bars you know I knew him before I
knew her I met her through that you know
so I was there and uh
and uh she came walking in the door and
uh she was tuned up John she was black
and blue you know and from him
so as the dad being an ex-marine and
being a tough dude he was a former boxer
nose Lakers like that right you know got
the little you know you know he took
some socks right bro George was a tough
older guy and as he's cocking his guns
and everything and I'm sitting in there
I said pops get stop stop man you you
can't do this where you're going this
can't happen you know it's like well I
said let's let me think here let me
think you know so
gathered to the guys that I knew that
would be great for to take care of this
situation not knowing what we're gonna
do again no Playbook right and just on
the spot happening you know so these two
had lived together and her real father
had a house and they were renting the
house from her real dad right so they
lived together in the house and uh so we
jumped in a vehicle we had
um George her stepdad take her over
there we gave her a little like valium
or xanax the the calmer down and for the
pain and stuff like that and um we went
went to the he drove her we drove
separately and uh you know we told her
we're gonna
pack up some of your stuff out of that
house we're going to get your stuff out
of the house you're going to call up
your dude your you know the guy and tell
him that he's going to come here and
grab all his stuff and tomorrow morning
your real dads come in here and change
and relax and you two are a wrap right
you're gonna tell him this right
and you know we knew the whole time
going back to this house when she made
this call from the house that he was
gonna come because
he would you know he would be sorry
afterwards he they'd get in a fight he'd
put his hands on her and then that was
the pattern yeah Peter and then he'd
come up and then he said I'm sorry and
stuff and she'd get back together with
him right then they'd stay together
right so when we were in the house and
she gave him a call on the phone and he
was like no Kendall I'm sorry I'm sorry
I just get a little aggravated and he
was kind of a jealous guy she was a good
looking girl nobody could look at her
one of them guys right and um he's a gay
guy right yeah he was a street dude yeah
he ran with some with some dudes and
stuff like that I like the calm Street
guys you know and uh you know and uh so
as she's got him on the phone and he
goes don't leave I'm on my way I'm on my
way and that's exactly what we were
waiting for right we were you know we
knew the deal right and um so
so when uh when he arrived there it was
very cold we just found out the dates
from putting all this together it was
December 15th in Chicago you know very
very cold you know below weather and
stuff like that and we're in a suburb
we're in a really nice suburb you know I
mean like you know in in this house it
was a really nice neighborhood so
when he uh arrived to the house her car
was out there you know because the dad
drove her car stepdad drove the car and
they walked out you wanted the car out
front yeah we wanted the car in front so
he could see she was there and stuff so
and they the dad knew that when the when
he knew arrived and that door opened the
front door where he came in
they were leaving they were getting out
the side door
so when he showed up in there and the
door got shut behind him
I was sitting on the couch
standing right sitting right there when
the lights popped on and you know and he
said hey
where's Kendall I said she's not here
well we're cars outside and not no more
you know so
um
that's where this story starts and you
know and you know there's a lot of
sensitive stuff but yeah I'm gonna tell
the you know because this is what did
send me to prison so
no plan I just knew that this had to be
rectified right that this he needed to
be taught a lesson not to do it
especially to somebody that I was so
close with that I love have loved for
the family sure he wasn't thinking about
that at the time but here we are in this
situation right so he walks in he walks
in he's with another guy right he's with
another guy yeah and and
the other guy that he was with
Kendall's sister told me a story that
one time when her ex was putting his
hands on her
the other guy stopped him and said
you're not doing this in front of me and
that happened to be that other guy and
and so what it I mean when they walk in
and they see you there yeah they were
definitely taken by surprise and they
were wide-eyed you know what I mean to
see me in there and to turn around and
see the two other boys there yeah all
big cats yeah long hair I was the only
one but the short hair they knew which
way it was padded up they knew it wasn't
let's sit down and let's let's have some
ice cream and sing Kumbaya yeah they
knew and I said to the dude I said hey I
heard the story this is what you did you
know you pulled him offer yes I did okay
and uh I'll tell it like this
we gave him a pass okay and uh I don't
want to get into where he went but we
gave him a pass okay so now it's me in
this this guy right a couple years
younger than me in the home and I tell
him this is how this is going to go down
you know it's me and you here don't
worry about these other two boys this is
this this is the get-go this is the time
and he was trying to tell me you know it
ain't like that it ain't like that but
you couldn't change my mind because I I
seen the results right
so things don't go his way there and you
know as as the court records go and we
had a you know say you know talk about
this in there you know we duct taped
them in into a chair and we a full roll
of duct tape and put him in a chair
and he got some beatings you know he
from me with with a ball bat through the
body right and uh you know giving him
the message with that and um you know
like I said man no plan John we don't
really know what we're gonna do we know
we're not going there to kill anybody
because a whole family's involved that
was never any kind of issue with us but
with myself in the room in two the two
of the other boys that were all high
strung guys you kind of never know where
that's going to go yeah I mean I knew if
I could speak for me and I know I wasn't
going to do anything but I I wild cards
are my two guys right you never know
what's gonna happen right and so you
know and then the whole time I'm driving
over it or I'm like because you know
this is before I ever went away and you
know I knew the Lord so I was like all
right Lord like you probably shouldn't
be doing this but you know
um so
things don't go good in the house for
him right we're in the middle of taking
care of him in this house right and uh
it's very cold like I said so I tell one
of the guys I said
go outside and start the car get this
car warmed up for us to go out there
we're gonna take him
and his body and we're gonna
drop them off at a forest preserve and
his buddy can go take care of him later
in the hospital take him to the hospital
right so that start go start the car up
so as he goes outside and starts the car
up and everything he comes running back
in
and he's you know winded out of breath
you know it's you know discombobulated
from what he's seeing and he goes hey
bro hey look out the blinds you know and
you know it's about 10 o'clock at night
from what I can remember it's night time
and I looked out the blinds I popped
open the blinds and it looked like right
now day all I seen was just like did the
sun come up like what's going on I look
and I couldn't it was so blinded on the
house I couldn't see past and I went to
a side window and looked out and I seen
all the Chicago SWAT vehicles and we
weren't in Chicago we were in a town
called Evergreen Park which is a suburb
like you know being around here
and I'm like I go man like the whole
entire SWAT team is you know out here
with lights shining and everything
and I said man I said they're they're
here how they hear well go check and see
and dude dude split
went to a local store down the street
like a 7-Eleven a White Hen like a
pantry I'll say
and there was a cop in there in
Evergreen Park cop and he told the cop
hey
the Hell's Angels melchance he grabbed
got my friend in a house they got him
kidnapped in a house well the Evergreen
Park police are like what so they call
Up Chicago and they have time to put
this together because we're in the house
for
45 50 you know 45 minutes an hour right
we're not like you know it's it's taken
a few minutes to you know give him some
messages right so
I'm like all right boys time to clean it
up they're coming in we know they're
coming in right so you know we cut them
out of the chair and you know you can't
I mean he's got a sweatshirt on it's
cold the duct tape is not coming off the
sweatshirt and we just cut them so we
can get up and out and what do you do
now you're trying to you know plan for
the best right so we're cleaning up the
house as much as we could and I'm having
a conversation with him come on let's go
sit at the kitchen table these boys are
ready to kick the doors in here you
brought me here right yeah I did okay I
didn't come here on my own right so
you're gonna do the right thing when
these guys come through the door and
you're going to say that this happened
on the street with your street crew guys
right okay I got you he's he was all on
the team right so
I'm at the table and they're over the
loudspeaker they're calling the phone
and we're not getting it right because
now her stepdad's not there she's not
there and her real dad's not there he
owns the house
well one of my guys is standing in front
of the door and they're there and
they're going open up the door and he's
like I can't open up the door he goes
this ain't our home we're just here
moving some of Kendall's stuff out right
and I look and I see he's just red
dotted right through the glass and
everything and I said hey bro get come
on come on and sit down right so they
kicked the doors in we're sitting there
like this right they come in we're like
we're not armed we're unarmed no weapons
in the house and stuff like that so they
grab us all handcuff us him too
bring us out throw us in the paddy
wagons and stuff and um and they go
through the house the whole nine yards
right so we go into this Evergreen Park
lock up because we committed the crime
right in our town right so they're gonna
run it we go into this cold lock up you
know me and me and the two brothers now
about one o'clock in the morning this is
like 10 something I'm saying about one
o'clock in the morning
um I'm laying there freezing right I got
my sweatshirt pulled down like a dress
I'm laying on a piece of metal it's just
me we're all in we're all in our own
individual cells
and I hear this girl's voice and I hear
Mal
Mal and I'm like wake up out of the
sleep and and I go Kendall and she goes
yeah and I go she's in the cell next to
me I said what how are you here she goes
they came and got me at the house and
arrested me and I said okay I said Relax
chill out George is your stepdad he'll
you know we're gonna go in the morning
get arraigned in this little town here
and stuff like that George got you you
didn't do nothing wrong I don't even
know why they grabbed you but you know
we got this you know so I see her in the
morning we go we're going to court you
know she's on one side they put her in
separator from us and we're on the other
side so it's just us three and her and
we're talking she tell me how they come
in the night and got her and you know so
she goes what are they charging me with
I go well I don't know what they're
charging us with we're gonna find out
very shortly here you know so we went in
the courtroom
hearing the charges that they that
they've made up in attempted murder and
kidnapping and home invasion and
everything and charged her with the
whole thing because they were putting it
together like thinking that she ran the
charger but she didn't she knew nothing
we didn't she didn't know we were doing
this fishing expedition in this house
because she wouldn't have went for it
obviously she kept forgiving him right
she would have said no let's just go get
my stuff home and let him go a separate
way so you know anyways they charged her
with all that stuff a few months later
when we were all going back to court and
stuff her lawyers and everything like
that got all her charges dropped you
know they didn't go further with hers
but now
so that's December 15th 16th we're in
arraignment and everything like that
right before Christmas well now they
find some guns in the house they find
some ski masks in the house all
scattered through the house and
everything like that so they're charged
and that's all our stuff they're
charging us with them
so they know Bond us and the judge says
the guns are getting ran for
fingerprints right now
um you know we're gonna when them come
back if these guys fingerprints are on
the guns I'll know Bond them I'll keep
them locked up until this trial goes on
or whatever but if they're fingerprints
ain't on the guns and there's you know
no weapons and stuff like that I'm gonna
have to set them a bond
so
December 24th Christmas Eve we go back
for the bond hearing no fingerprints on
the guns from us right gloves you know
no fingerprints right so
um they give us a bond a high crazy Bond
we get out I get out Christmas morning
you know I forget it was dark out six
seven o'clock in the morning the guys
come and you know their lawyers come and
the treasurer comes and they post the
bond 10 of whatever the bond was you
know it was the bond was like
300 Grand so 30 000 you know to get me
out you know 20 to get the other guy out
10 you know it was it was all like that
so we get out and we fight start
fighting the case from the street
you know month after month you have to
show up in court to be present you know
even if it's a status here and we had to
be there right and they have him tucked
away somewhere to you know because he's
gonna you know tell the story of what
happened in the house now so they got
him hidden out somewhere and stuff like
that
we're going to court going to court a
few months into going to court you know
um January February or March and stuff
like that
our lawyers give us a call up and they
said hey guys here's the deal they you
guys got to come in to the to they want
to do hair hair samples from you guys
they found some hair fibers in the ski
masks
and they want you guys to give ahead of
girl the sides of my hair out and
everything like that they took you know
25 samples here 25 they took like 50
hair fibers from each of us the two
other boys had real long hair I mean
down to the middle of their backs right
so you know they'd have to grown on
there taking hair samples
our lawyer says Mel you know the drill
if if it's your hair fibers and the
masks
it's going to be hard to beat home
invasion it's going to show that you
guys came in with intent to do this not
just to move her out right you guys are
saying these ski masks ain't yours
they're they're all his in his home
where he lives with her the whole nine
yards I go I get it my lawyer's name was
Jeff I said I get a Jeff you know so we
do the hair samples and you don't give
them the hair
about three weeks later
lawyer calls me up and he goes hey
I don't know how he goes but the hair
fibers that they found in the ski mask
were his
and I said okay well they found him
under his pillows
so when my dude was going around
cleaning the house up he threw things in
his room right
under his pillows he threw the ski mask
in his closet he threw the gut they
threw the guns right where him and
Kendall live together right this is
where I say I was telling you a story
the hand of God by the grace of God they
found that so we get an expert that
comes in to one of the Quirk cases and
says if you went into a Target
and you try to ski mask on and you
pulled that thing off it's a 97 chance
you're gonna leave a fiber in there wow
so if we would have had the mass on with
the long hair and everything like that
should have been our fibers they were
his under from under his pillow the guns
none of our fingerprints on them he had
a case where him and another dude jacked
up a a convenience store with ski mask
and a gun
prior case prior predicate for him a
case so now the lawyer said these are
his your honor obviously he's a street
guy he's got guns in his house Kendall
takes the stand and said I seen them
guns wow I seen them bulletproof vests
because it was best involved I seen them
ski masks in my house the whole time I
was with this guy wow wow so uh that
there goes the home invasion the the
predicate Act of we were planning this
the conspiracy and everything like that
right so there goes that so when the
trial part comes to come around we did a
bench trial with the with the judge and
everything like that
and uh you know after you know five days
of the trial and everything one of the
charges was the Lesser charge the Lesser
charge of all of them with the home the
home invasion the kidnapping they call
them class X felonies in Illinois that's
what holds the time then there was an
aggravated battery part that didn't you
know that didn't hold all that time the
judge found us guilty of the aggravated
battery
and we were sentenced from there so you
know
going through all this and seeing how
this played out
I took the stand and in the trial on our
behalf because we had to talk about the
elephant that was in the room they had a
sweatshirt that was full of duct tape
full of blood how could we say we didn't
duct tape this guy to a chair when here
is the evidence right here
the duct tape had one of the members one
of the guys fingerprints on him which
was kind of shocking to me right but
um they found the fingerprints on the
duct tape you know
um so you know the lawyer my lawyers
they had their own individual lawyers my
lawyer was kind of like the head lawyer
of all this and he said you can't you're
gonna have to take the stand Mel you got
no criminal record at the time you're
gonna have to say yes you did go in
there your anger got the best of you you
put them in a chair and you beat them
with that baseball bat
you know everything else has fallen the
home invasion the kidnapping you're not
going to get around this battery part
right it's just can't it's not beatable
you go in there and get on the stand and
you lie about this and they're showing
all this the judge is going to know
you're lying about everything right so
that's what I did I got to understand
and said this was me
you know I brought these two guys with
me I did this you know the whole nine
yards and and this is what what happened
we asked we duct taped them in a chair
your honor might they got the best of
meat because you know I'm so close to
the family and everything like that so
they found us guilty of
the aggravated battery part of it and
they gave us four years which the
courtroom erupted because you know as
Lou is back there telling you half of
the courtroom was federal agents it's a
state case State cops Federal cops and
the other half the other the courtroom
was our family friends in the club
so when the verdicts were coming down
not guilty of of kidnapping you know you
heard not guilty of of home invasion
once the last class X was read and it
was not guilty well then they knew that
it was short time now for the aggravated
battery so the the FED side and the
state side they're getting oh man ah
[__] everything like that our guys
are cheering right you got different
things going on yeah so he kind of
cleared everybody out of the courtroom
yeah he wasn't having it you know and um
guilty of aggravated battery you know
okay the state's attorney jumps up all
right your honor I want to revoke their
bond they're a Flight Risk blah blah
blah our lawyers say they've been
showing up here for 14 months fighting
this case we want to say leave them out
on the street the judge said I'm not
leaving them out in the street revoked
our bonds we went to Cook County you
know jail that day you know went on the
bus the county in our normal clothes and
stuff like that
satin Cook County for 30 something days
a month and a half or something like
that came back for sentencing and the
sentencing range for us was three to ten
okay so the feds the cops everybody's
got pressure on this judge because like
Lou had said I was the Target right we
got him we didn't got him where we
wanted to get him but he got himself
here and let's give this kid to you know
they were putting pressure on the judge
you know judge sentenced each one of us
to four years
and one of the members that was in there
in that room was out on parole he just
came home from The Joint he was not even
home a year so he was out on parole we
thought for sure he was going to get
some more time being out on parole and
catching another case
the judge gave us all four across the
board you know and uh you know we then
we went off you know to the state
penitentiaries you know that was the
first time I was away so it was uh that
was the start of the journey as we were
talking about you know but now the
government was really hot because now
I'm off the streets for a few years I'm
not committing any more predicate acts
so my stuff stops they're still going on
with what's happening from you know the
the war just ceased 97 and stuff like I
said I went away right after that so you
know now they were you know not too
happy they didn't want me to go away you
know as I found out later they were
telling the locals listen unless this
guy's doing something horrible don't
pull him over for speeding on his
motorcycle yeah don't pull him over
because you might thought he had an
extra drink leaving the bar leave that
for us let him have some free run so he
can hang himself you know and I hung
myself on my own and you know the guys
that were doing the case were like [__]
we're not trying to get him for four
years we're trying to you know Pom-Pom
sunlight into a federal prison because
we got him for so long you know and then
that's where I come home and then you
know to change my life and run in the
nightclubs and just I never went back so
I never had another predicate act
outside of that year in 1997. I always
say I really never rode with the club
again from that time on because I was
home I was on my non-association I'm
still in the club but I couldn't see the
club or be around the club and it gave
that gave me that time to really you
know get in with my family like I said I
wanted to do a run the nightclubs and
start a different life you know and then
when I quit the club it was like I said
it was shortly after that then the RICO
came so tell about that guy about your
relationship with that guy and and where
that went to as much as you can yeah
because obviously we've had a lot of
discussions about about this thing and
and and and and that that event for him
changed him as well changed him as well
took a took a crazy turn for me and him
right so
that's 97.
in 2012. so when I come home from prison
uh the first time you know I have a
restraining order on me against him I
can't be I can't be in the same room as
them if I walk in a bar and he's there I
I gotta leave right
so
I never see him or nothing like that I
go away for the RICO I come home from
the RICO 2008 in 2012 I walk into a bar
a couple of my friends not not in the
club no more not no club guys a couple
of my friends
and I turn the corner and I see him with
a whole crew of friends you know 12 15
guys and I'm thinking oh boy okay well
this is the time he's got a whole crew
this is the time if they're going to do
it they're going to do it now I can't
tell my two friends
they all know the story of why I went
away but they none of them knew him
these are my outside friends they didn't
know him and I can't tell him in a loud
bar why all they're looking at me in
them and I'm going to be over like this
and I'm like I know these two cats got
my back no matter if there's a hundred
guys so I wasn't worried about when we
were getting busy if we had to get busy
and he sees me and I walk over to him
and he says hello and I say hello and I
put my hand out and he pulled me into
him and we gave each other a hug
you know and at first I was like what's
is he pulling me in because we're gonna
go and I didn't know where his head was
and I said to him I said hey man how are
you I said his name I said how are you
doing man he goes I'm okay and I said
man it's been a long time honey goes
yeah and he said uh
can I run and walk over and introduce
you to some of my family and I said yeah
for sure man let's go and I went over
and they all knew the story right I went
over and started meeting people hey how
you doing so my two friends are blind
they're just saying hello to people just
like you know we meet a lot of people
so we go up to the bar and I said come
on let me get everybody a drink he said
no I'm gonna get myself I'm getting them
let me get everybody a drink every tell
your crew let's go let's get a drink so
me and him are standing at the bar and
we're side by side with each other and
everybody's around my two guys are in
the back of you know five feet away
talking to some of his friends and he
looked at me and he said Mel
thanks for not killing me in that house
and I said boy man things would have
been different and both of our Lives had
that happen obviously you wouldn't be
here and I'd be doing a million years
in in the penitentiary I said God had a
plan
whether we knew it at the time or not he
had a plan and I go and I'm gonna hear
some I'll tell you something good I
heard about you I heard you're doing
amazing in life and you're running a
huge gym a chain you're doing great I
heard you you got a couple girls kids
and he said I do and I said I hear her
man people tell me what's going on I
said I'm I'm proud of you for that man
you know I said listen
that guy I was back then and that guy
you were back then is obviously ain't
who we are now
and I said so you know we're blessed
when we didn't know it right and you
know we couldn't both had tears in our
eyes right you know so you know like I
said my guys didn't know they were just
you know so now some of his family and
friends are going wow that's so amazing
to see this Han my friends are like yeah
okay but they don't know what he's
talking about right yeah so I go to go
to the bathroom and and you know use the
bathroom so one of my guys comes with he
goes yeah I gotta take a leak you know
so we go in there and I said hey bro you
don't know who that is right he goes no
I go you know the story in the house and
he goes yeah and I go that's him and he
goes well no wonder why his family was
saying that he goes everything's cool
and I said everything's cool man the
guys changed his life he's a different
man we both Grew From This and and I
like the cat man and uh we we continued
on right so you know we've seen it you
know we've seen it until that time I see
him now he's come to the nightclubs I
get a call hey man so he's down here at
the nightclub let him in what let him in
man we're good man we're all good
everything's good and people are like
okay you know so you know that started
our journey together where we became
friends and he started texting me on
Merry Christmas and Happy Thanksgiving
and vice versa now we'll we'll fast
forward it many years later my wife
little Mel throws me a 50th birthday
party in Chicago I'm already living in
Florida it's four years ago
and I said okay let's go we'll go back
there she throws me a big 50th birthday
party guy there had to be three 350
people there Honolulu comes Bayless
comes like there's every Walk of Life
that I've been with there's some old
club guys there's my high school or I'm
grade school teachers there's the kids I
played Kick the Can with I mean it was
you know I was very loved in the
community I grew up as a kid with all
the kids so everybody was at this
birthday party it was like a who's who
in the zoo federal agents
Mafia guys Street guys bikers priests my
Pastor Steve Pastor Steve that's been in
my life I mean how about it we were
looking around like look at this room
right like the cast of characters here
right
that was on a Friday
Saturday we go out downtown we're gonna
go hit some clubs for the birthday right
these these downtown cats want to throw
me a big party in the club so there's
about 50 of us right that roll down
there
all of a sudden I hear get a tap on my
shoulder I said hey I hear hey bro and I
turn around it's him the guy right and I
go hey man what are you doing here and I
give him a hug and he goes it's my
cousin's birthday you guys got the same
birthday
we're throwing his party down here his
fate would have it throwing my party
down here it was called bottle blonde
right bottle blonde was the club and I
said oh that's cool man he goes can I
bring my you know what he goes let me
you know come over and say hi to the
crew and I go bring him over here man I
go bring him over here I go look we got
bottles everything's out I go I know
these guys really good man come on over
here
somebody walks away I grab Chris Bayless
because Chris knew him from the grand
jury stuff because later in life I did
that state time but when the when the
feds hit me with the racketeering they
use that as a predicate act for a
conspiracy part they charged us with a
conspiracy to kill him in that house
because I brought two other Pals angels
with me so it was kind of like the
double deck thing right so I said to my
Lord how does this happen right and he
goes well they're charging you with the
conspiracy part so um so Chris knew him
Chris had you know interviewed him for
the for the grand jury and stuff like
that
so when he walked away I said that Chris
I said Chris do you see that that God I
was just talking to me he goes yeah I
said did you know who that was and he
goes no I don't know who it was and I
told him his name he goes wow really he
goes he looks different I go put on a
little bit of weight right I go but
that's him I said I'm going to tell him
when he comes back you know so I told
him I said you know that is and he looks
he goes he looks familiar to me I said
yeah that's the ATF agent and he goes oh
yeah he goes man they were hounding me
hard on the federal side of it you know
he goes but uh I just didn't want no
part of it but they subpoenaed him you
know what I mean so we got to see him
there hang out and everything and to
this day we you know I don't see him I'm
not home in Chicago anymore and uh but
we taxed happy you know uh birthday
Merry Christmas Happy Thanksgiving he's
got a family he's doing great and I have
the utmost respect for him because you
know if if you're gonna like how can I
judge somebody for their past right I
mean me of all people man I got a pretty
rough pass that I created for myself you
know and I'm not that hypocrite guy so
you know that's why the story sensitive
to me right bro and hadn't I went to
prison that first time I I wasn't
rethinking life you know I mean I was a
young dude with girls in money and
a power thing going on here and you know
we became you know this notorious
underworld Outlaws in US you weren't
pulling me out of that life I loved it
right I was just focused I had Tunnel
Vision on that and that only nothing
else mattered sure I loved my family my
mother and father and my daughter and
everything but they were well taken care
of my mother and father had a you know
great career Danielle was raised right I
didn't have to really worry that she
wasn't there there was a wrong path
there I was so focused on the club
you know and I told him I said I have to
tell that the part of the story that's a
journey that we were kind of on together
and it's what opened my eyes up and made
me think like okay I'm this is not how I
want to live right so that has to be
told as we said but to tell it
respectfully listen if the guy didn't
change and he was that same cat today it
would be a different story here I would
have got a little bit deeper into things
but she did man and I have to love that
and honor that because we were young man
we were in our 20s at the time right I
can't do the math but if I'm 54 and
Ninth I was born in 69 97 we were young
kids you know in In Living both living
violent worlds right he lived in a
violent world right that he created I
lived in a violent world that week that
I created and we met
and that made something right how that
did it made something and it changed him
and it changed me so let me let me read
back at that 50th birthday party
after he's over there he said to me he
goes
that's little Mel over there you know
because we follow each other on social
media and I said that's little Maui call
my life Melissa melon Mel right and he
goes can I meet her and I said
absolutely and I walked him over and I
said babe
I said you don't know who this is there
and she goes no I said this is who this
is
that his name she goes oh wow she goes
listen
she said
what a story and she goes in in in
it changed my husband's life
I I heard it changed yours and he was
just sitting there and you know and and
all of a sudden he grabbed her and he
hugged her and Terrace came out and I
hugged the both of them tears came out
of my eyes and I'm like here we are Lord
right with my 50th birthday party and
he's the journey that we had all these
years later right it was just cool you
know it was deep it was felt you know
when I felt him and I know he didn't
have any
animosity you know he could have
probably had 15 20 guys come and try to
find me somewhere the Revenge kick right
and he wasn't on that so that's why
where I say with him I respect him a lot
and we still stay in touch with each
other and he knows you know I mean he
don't mind not know what we have going
on that we're ready to talk about but he
knows that that's part of the Journey of
that I have to tell I have to talk about
that story because that's what set me to
prison and that's what started changed a
trajectory of the way my life was going
right because I go away to the State
Penitentiary everybody knows who I'm at
who I am you know what's prison like for
you
um sucks as far as you know I you know I
couldn't go home at night time that cell
door shut right I you know I got locked
up like everybody else strip searched
like everybody else you know
an inmate like everybody else right not
seeing my family you know that part you
know suck but as far as in there with
the inmates and everything no no issues
bro I'm 290 pounds and being you know
still everybody's knowing me as the the
president of the Hell's Angels in there
I know all the street Crews I know the
gangster disciple boss at the time of
ice Lord boss I know them all so I'm
kicking it in there with everybody that
I knew and that were in these joints
that they shipped me around and I got
the I got the old diesel therapy they
didn't keep me in one prison but they
shipped me around in the state of
Illinois you know for a while right and
uh so no problems no issues and stuff
the guards were cool a lot of guards
rode so they you know they like that you
know guards are normal guys right that
that live around the prison and it's
just their gigs right so no issues at
all you know as you Lou will say and of
course you know when you get Chris on
here we're saving that for a special
time and uh you know he's like yeah you
know Mel is you know making out with the
guards here and you know they were all
hearing the stories right so you know I
was taking advantage of whatever I could
in there you know and people coming to
me and stuff like that so easy time as
far as how how how common is that making
out with making out with female guards
um yeah I mean I don't know if it was
you to happen a lot but there's some
female guards and you know and we you
know they're running the Pod and locking
us up and stuff like that and you know
you're you know you ain't doing much
listen I always knew this if a female
guard gets involved with an inmate you
know you've we've heard stories where
some got impregnated and stuff like that
well they're charging them that's a
charge for them yeah right and I never
wanted to put that on anybody to to go
that far but I sure was making out with
them having some fun and hey can you
bring me some Tylenol PM so I could
sleep I never asked for anything outside
of that you know having as much of a
good time as I possibly can in a bad
situation and some pretty rough State
penitentiaries right where some serious
cats were doing life and stuff like that
I come in with a four-year sentence like
a sleepover right to some of these dudes
but I knew everybody and there was no
problems you know so
um
like I said just just missing the family
and just missing home you know and young
and when I came home you know in there
is what I said when I started
concentrating on my relationship with
the Lord you know I was I had a little
uh uh prayer group that we had you know
a lot of guys were reluctant to come and
do it because you know some guys think
like it shows a sign of weakness like uh
or you know we're at least thugs but
we're you know but I didn't care man and
in in in the thing grew and you should
some of the guys that were part of you
know this devotional team were some bad
cats but that wanted to know the Lord
and they wanted to know the purpose and
stuff like that and I guess by me doing
it it was making it like hey man this
this this dude's doing it he ain't
afraid to show his faith and his love
for the Lord in the middle of this joint
I didn't care you know what I mean I I
was at church on Sundays in there and
stuff like that and then I started you
know and then they shipped me and they
told me why they were shipping me out of
this one joint they said here's the deal
we're going to show you a videotape
because I asked them why are you
shipping me I'm a model loot guy I've
never even been in a fight here what's
going on well we're going to show you
why it's Fourth of July right yeah it
was just Fourth of July here you are
eating over in the in the Gangster
Disciple Camp now you're over here and
eating with the Vice Lords in their camp
now you're over there with the ab's
eating in their Camp I go okay I still
don't understand the problem yeah we're
not having that off to another joint you
know and then they [__] you know they
don't want that you know what I mean
that maybe they thought I was trying to
pull some coup or bring people together
wasn't happening I just got along with
everybody I wasn't in their business
right that we didn't have each business
with each other I knew all them cats
from the street their bosses as we were
talking about and I had a respect for
them and they had respect for me you
know respect goes a long way right and
and when you're not coming into a listen
you want to come into Penitentiary 290
pounds I don't care who you're the
leader of if you're doing this you're
gonna find it
they're going to accommodate you but
when you're laid back and that's what I
wanted to do I just wanted to do my time
and get out of there and focus on me and
if I could have helped anybody along the
way which I did you know Chris will tell
you a lot of stories Bayless will tell
you a lot of stories where he's like man
Mel had the federal sentencing
guidelines in one hand in the Bible and
the other and said boys what do you
where's your choice
you got some time we got to do the time
we can't leave you want to do it you
know peacefully or you know do you want
to go run around and be a gladiator
because they're gonna they're gonna
accommodate you you know so the time was
okay as far as that went you know and I
got home and was able to you know be
with the family and stuff and like I
said I never wanted my relationship done
with the Lord I want to be a hypocrite I
didn't want to say okay you got me
through that I'm gonna go right back it
was a little rough John because when I
did come home from that first one
everything was there still there for the
taken for me everybody wanted okay he's
home now right even though he's on a
non-association let's make sure he's
okay let's make sure this is here this
if I wanted to get back into the drug
trade them cats were right there for me
and stuff but you know I didn't and
there was a few times where you know I
was down in my nightclubs big nightclubs
that I ran all the security and and some
old school dudes would come in and
they're like hey man you good here I'm
like I'm good here man you know wow
we're making a thousand bucks a week at
that time it's good money running these
clubs and everything like that I'm good
that's good money man hey we got these
keys of cocaine they're 16 Grand they're
going for 30. you want to come on to
come up and I'm like no guys I
appreciate it but come on man you're
pulling me in the quicksand right right
because I knew if I stuck my foot
stuck my toe in that pool I'm gonna go
all the way back in I'm gonna grab a
bike I'm Gonna Wanna Get in the club I'm
gonna it's gonna remind me so I always
say it's like I'm like an alcoholic
right I can't not gonna smell it a sip a
smell a Jack Daniels bottle because I'm
gonna want to down it right and that's
the way it is with my old life right we
all say I don't ride a motorcycle I
don't go to strip clubs I don't
go into that environment because it's a
fine line for me
to fight that battle to where roads
gonna be coming out and I'm going to be
thinking about all that stuff this is
great and I'm gonna be right back in the
same mess and then I'm never coming home
again you know I don't have any my
criminal history is at maxed out you
know the federal guidelines across the
tops or criminal history across the left
side is your your points offense and
they come here and that's where that
interjects and they give you the months
right criminal history starting at zero
to one and it goes to five I'm a five
right so I don't have the luxury of you
know you know having a screw up and
that's that's how I've lived my life
since then you know
and uh it's it's it's what works for me
and it's it's it's it's what I know you
know was it a continual sort of Promise
of of faith and Fidelity or was there
one conversation that you remember
specifically that that that you said
okay from here on in that that that's
done yeah so when when I went away on on
the RICO and you know and at first I was
like all right why Lord you know like
you you got me on this different path
here I see a lot of people I'm able to
help out
in the old lifestyle a lot of guys left
left different clubs not only the Hell's
Angels different clubs and came to me
and said man we're seeing what you're
doing and we we admire it and I was
explaining how you got to do it you have
to walk away and not you know return and
then now here I'm back in the in the
joint right and in pain for the old and
when I got down on my knees and that
that that cold cell that they had me in
I was I wasn't in a federal prison yet I
was in a holding facility no bond on the
RICO when they kicked our doors in that
morning and we went that judge was like
no bond because the predicate X and the
RICO was off from the war stuff you know
so you know no bond with the feds and
I'm sitting in there and I when I got
down on my knees and I said all right I
don't know why or what the what the
purpose is but you do
you know I like I said I knew the Lord I
was the altar boy I came from a strict
Catholic Family of knowing the word my
mom and dad instilled it we prayed over
every meal and we were that family
and I said but I'm going to trust in you
and you know whether I get 20 years or
nine years
you know the rip Lord and I'm gonna sit
back I'm gonna jump in the raft of the
Lazy River of Life and just as I say God
did this in my life I made the dumb
decisions and I ran down them them crazy
I call them dead-end streets but he
protected me right I mean you see the
Tombstones you hear about the the the
deaths you hear about guys doing life in
prison I'm making all these decisions
and he's protecting me I'm I'm you know
I should not be sitting here right them
dudes were trying to knock my head off
my shoulders and the FED boys were
trying to put me and pump me sunlight
into a prison for a hundred years right
and here we are doing your podcast and
for a bigger reason but I I always
trusted him and I said I'm not going to
question you I'm gonna put it neutral
you're driving the car
and you know now that I'm home I always
have a funny prayer and I said all right
Lord
if I don't ever have to sit in an 8x10
and eat some Ramen noodles again I'd
definitely be a happy camper but if
there's a purpose for that because you
need me to go and touch one person's
life
of where I'm at I get it but if I don't
have to please
not trying to but that's my trust in the
Lord and that's how I've been since
2005. I don't stress on anything
talking about our project four years in
the making you know people you know
wouldn't have patience like come on
let's get this thing going let's get
this thing um it's it's his it's his
show and I'm just sitting back and being
the vessel and living in it and it makes
makes things much easier for me because
you know when I get frazzled and try to
take things into my own hands look what
it does I it's not a good outcome for me
I I have that like like Chris got a good
saying Bayless got a good saying he goes
Mel never had a plan B
it was run in do what you do and
whatever happens happens you know some
guys are like all right let's try to get
away with this now if something happened
to us back in the day
for instance one of our guys gets jumped
in a bar by some by some construction
guys he's in there with his old lady
gets jumped in the bar he's got his
patch on they beat him up they see who
he is he gets to get cops come some
patrons call the cops cops come break it
up you want to press charges our guy
goes I'm not pressing any charges I'm
good see you guys later they give us a
call pagers go off we're all out at this
time there's like seven of us and we're
all hanging out in strip club we all get
the nine when we come what's what's
going on Butch you good no I just got
where at night moves right now who are
you with I'm with my old lady in the
parking lot where's the dudes they're
inside the bar but the cops just left
they're all down the street right here
at this at this local gas station and uh
worse I don't split we're coming
so we come to the parking lot you know
and he's out there with his old lady and
stuff and I said all right boys
everybody give their guns to his old
lady put him in the trunk of the car we
don't need them we're gonna go in here
and [__] these boys World up right here
for for hurting him right
so Wow Let's Take a Ride around the
block see if the cops are nice I'll do
it jump in my vet so me and me and the
member we jump in my vet we drive around
oh six squads in the in in the gas
station from here to your you know your
kitchen door right but I'm like
don't do not tell these guys when we go
back these these guys are sitting here
who cares we're going in there and we're
jacking these dudes up right he goes
okay we got the sap gloves on right so
we walk in and dudes turn around and
it's ah bam we're getting them bottles
broken sticking them in the ribs and a
melee right right and uh
the cops get the call they're like they
think they walked there right they were
so close right
so as we're exiting the bar and we're
all going to get in the vehicles they
shut the two parkings you know the exit
spots down and we're we're in the we're
in the parking lot right so we get out
of car it's freezing cold we jump out of
blood all over my pants you know the
cops got us right you know uh what's
going on here I said ah I said man our
dude got jumped in the bar and he goes
yeah 30 minutes ago you guys came back
for the retaliation I said nobody's
saying not Ryan where it is what it is
arrest us or whatever we're doing so
they get the guys they got out some
ambulances come guys are pretty are
pretty banged up These Guys these
construction dudes and uh the chief of
police of the town I know him from the
gym he comes he's he's off it's it's at
night time it's 11 o'clock you know at
night time
he comes and he sees me and stuff and he
comes over he's like you okay I said
yeah I'm okay and he goes and your guy
got jumped there and they go yeah and he
goes okay he goes well the guys are over
there he goes I'll be right back well
this Chief goes and tell these guys hey
guys you guys are gonna press charges I
heard huh yeah we're pressing charges
one guy's going to the hospital he got
stuck pretty good with some with a bear
bottle and stuff like that and they're
banged right I mean with hammers and the
whole nine yards
and he goes okay he goes that's cool he
goes but I I don't have a horse in the
race he tells him he goes I'm going to
tell you guys something
you know who they were and you see the
big dude that's out there right and he's
he's the president and stuff and he
loves his brothers
and they're gonna know who you guys are
now I we can't protect you from that we
they're going to get your addresses
they're gonna get everything once it
goes into the court system they're gonna
know who you guys are you jumped that
guy
and now they're here so if I'm just
saying if that's what you want we're
going to go ahead and do it and they
started thinking and he goes you know I
can't go either way with you you want to
do it he goes but I'm going to let you
know because these other cops are
zealous to get these guys it could be a
problem
so about 10 minutes later we're all
huddled up because we're cold right we
got short sleeve shirts on because we
just went in there like this we're all
kind of huddled up and everything like
that and uh we hear we got a gun because
they were searching vehicles and I'm
like they got a gun
well one of my guys didn't give his gun
up and I can't blame him for that
because what if they had one now a gun
gets pulled out we're gonna throw a
hammer at him yeah so he brought the gun
in and ditched it in the car so they
popped him with the gun right and all of
a sudden the chief comes over and he
goes hey boys
no don't we weren't cuffed up he goes
don't cuff him up they're no one's
pressing charges and you hear the normal
cops like what do you mean we just
talked to them and the chief goes I I'm
just came from there they don't want to
press charges so we don't have nothing
going on and uh so we were able to to
walk out of that got our guy out from
getting pinched with the gun in the
morning time and you know stuff like
that so you know that's the way we were
yeah one got hurt we felt it yeah and we
were there man there was no plan B like
what are we gonna do to get at it we're
gonna go Jack these dudes up and
whatever happens happens right you know
we all kind of knew the penitentiary was
definitely in our future and the grave
sites right we always just say that I
used to have an old saying and I used to
tell one of the guys save me a good spot
on your chest for the tombstone for me
and they'd say I don't say that and I'm
like well how am I not going to be there
kind of the poster child right how is
that not going to happen so you know it
was uh like I said by the grace of God
that uh you know I'm here a lot of us
were are still here you know a couple
casualties a couple brothers did get
killed on both sides and you know was
part of the part of the turmoilage on
but this good male this guy that you are
now that's just spreading so much light
and and and love
do you make a decision to do that every
day and and and can you give me an exam
like can you give me an example of how
that fills you and and and how you're
sort of propelled to keep living that
way yeah I don't think it's a decision
that I have to consciously make right
like I you know I'm not so habitualized
yeah yeah I get up in the morning time
and you know I spend some time with with
the Lord right I fellowship with him you
see I do the devotionals in the morning
time right on my social media I video it
and read the devotionals and we lift up
brothers and sisters that people are
asking for you know I know Sydney and
you know the the angle family have asked
for to lift some people up that were
sick or going through some stuff so we
lift them up in the morning time we'll
just say their first name we don't need
to know what they're going through he
does all right let's lift up John Let's
lift the bear and let's lift them out
you know and we do that and it became a
thing where I do it Monday through
Friday every morning we do it we call it
the John 3 16 devotional team and
there's people that are part of this and
watch this from all around the world
Australia Europe right and and we're
fellowshipping with each other like that
way and we're lifting brothers and
sisters up and stuff like that so you
know when I said I let him run
everything I do so it ain't like I got
to say okay let me let me be a good guy
today it's just who I became right by
his grace right and and I see the people
that are a part of this devotional team
as we call ourselves you know and uh
some bad cats that were some bad cats
back in the day that got out of their
organizations and and want to know how
did you do it now I want to know that
relationship that I see you having with
the Lord how can I know it call out to
him I'm nobody special he loves us all
the same he doesn't like me better than
anybody I just happen to hear him
calling upon my heart and I said here I
am you know so that's you know something
that's just part of my day I love it I
don't miss a day I did the devotionals
for the last two days from the hotel
right and I do it every morning you know
Monday through Friday I don't do it on
the weekends just because I'm always
traveling with the bodybuilding stuffer
with Core Medical and uh so Monday
through Friday doesn't we've been doing
this now for I think we're like three
and a half years and uh it's cool man
and I I get the fellowship you know some
90 of people I never met you know all
from overseas and stuff but they're
giving me DMs I have dudes from other
motorcycle clubs that say hey man we're
not into this no more how did you do it
we want to know the the love you've been
in in the way you feel we want to know
the lord well this is how you do it you
know so it's just part of the it's part
of the journey that he had that same 100
miles an hour that same devotion that
same commitment that you had over there
that it's just going the other way it's
just going the other way now yeah and
it's just empowering yeah and as you
know as you always say and people always
say you know like you you made a good
comment one time you said Mel is just
genuinely really happy and humbled to be
here and to be doing what he's doing
right and I am too I'm just grateful and
humbled that I'm in the position to be
that way you know and when sometimes
when it gets hectic and I'm answering
the DMS and there's you know 50 60 70 of
them you know where you know we're
lifting up people that's no problem I
put them in my notes because I'll forget
as soon as I see a DM and you know can
you lift up Jill can you lift up I'm
putting them in my notes for the morning
but when people are asking me stuff and
I'm voice messaging them back like we do
we voice you know text the talk you know
where they hear my voice and I tell them
hey brother hang tight man
it's not the answer with suicide brother
God loves you man and he's you didn't
find me on on accident there's a reason
that you're reaching out to me if you're
if you're telling me you don't feel it
in your heart anymore to be part of that
crew you're in there's a reason you
don't you know you're not I wasn't
calling anybody or reaching out to
anybody back in the day because I wanted
to get out of the crew yeah you know
what I mean yeah yeah so and you see how
it is and you made that comment you know
and a lot of people do they're like
Mel's just grateful and humbled
to be where he's at and to be a servant
right you know that's what that's what
Jesus did when he was here right he was
a servant as you know right then I feel
like then I thank him for being a vessel
and to see that in allowing me to see
the things that have changed not only in
my life but people's life around you
know you know our boy said do you know
what I mean we you know you're soon to
be brother-in-law and uh you know my
partner at Core Medical in the last five
and a half years I've been around him
I've seen such a huge change in him sure
you know and I'm not taking all the
credit but I know he get he says man you
changed my life around he said I know
he's told you that I mean I think I mean
I've heard that from a lot of people now
and I know it firsthand tell me about uh
tell me about Dwayne Johnson
how did he come into your life all right
so uh you know I'd met him a long time
ago in the wrestling ring you know me
and me and Hulk me and Terry our 30-year
friends right and uh Terry was back in
the day was like man you you need to be
in the ring you should be wrestling here
and stuff like that but you know when I
was you know you know running the angels
in Chicago I didn't want a job I didn't
want to punch a clock no matter how much
money they were trying to give me I just
wanted to live on my own terms you know
and so I just you know respectfully but
I loved wrestling I grew up a wrestling
fan so I was bouncing around and seeing
Terry seeing Twain and passing you know
he knew who I was and I knew of course I
was a big rock fan but in 2017 we ran
into each other at a Mr Olympia DJ was
gonna get up on stage and talk about
stuff the seven Buck production company
was going to do with the Olympia the
bodybuilding to bring it more mainstream
and um so when he was there and I seen
him before I could say man DJ
big fan I haven't seen you in a long
time and I got a message from Terry
because Terry and his dad were very
tight got it you know and he's stopped
and kneeled down next to me because we
were the Press pit was behind us and he
goes hey and I just heard your whole
story I never knew what happened to you
and I heard your story and you're
working for Jim mannion you know helping
run the ifbb and NPC and he goes I love
it man he goes uh I gotta go in the back
he goes you coming in the back he goes
let's chat back there and I said okay so
he went up on stage gave it gave his
speech and everything and when he got
behind the you know the scenes behind
the backstage
when I went back there he was surrounded
you know everybody wanted a picture with
DJ and you know the bodybuilders and
everybody the pros were all back there
and they're in in their in their
opposing trucks taking pictures with him
right he was bombarded and I'm like I'm
not gonna go hold that dude up man you
know and I didn't and I didn't see him
he split out the back door and then
probably you know six months later a
year later 2018 came
people were coming at me to write book
write a book write a book on my life
story I was didn't want to do it but
basically because I was actually too
lazy and I didn't want to go onto a book
signing tours right I just wasn't
interested bro right I'm like let me sit
him in the pool yeah I got a career
going on I'm with Sid we're doing core
I'm running the bodybuilding stuff you
know
and a couple networks called me up and
they wanted one wanted to do a reality
show with me and they wanted to beat a
ghost hunt and I was like ah it doesn't
even sound cool right like I don't want
to do it so
um
Terry actually told me he's like you
shouldn't reach out to Dwayne and just
you know pick his brain on you know
because you don't know that stuff and
you know what what would be a right move
for you and I said I'm not going to do
that I don't know I'm like that I'm not
the guy that's gonna go bother somebody
and I definitely wasn't trying to get
into the highway Hollywood scene when I
want to be an actor or anything like
that and I didn't know what to do so I
did reach out to him and he goes man Mal
I I didn't know you were interested in
telling your story and I said neither
did I I'd go but here I am and I got
some people coming at me and I don't
want to make any wrong decisions I don't
know if I want to make any decision you
know and he said okay so let me ask you
one question
so now this was uh
black Wednesday the day before
Thanksgiving
Frankie what did we start this in 19 me
and you you were going to ask me okay it
was black Wednesday and he says how much
of the a can you talk about how much of
your pass can you talk about because
that's going to determine because Mel
you're in such a different place in your
life and you're inspiring to me myself
he says and to everybody around you I
hear nothing but good when people say
Mel works for us or Mel does this with
us and they're like what a what an
amazing dude what a gentleman what is
this and that but how much of the old
stuff can you tell and I said well I can
tell it I paid the price for it I'm home
from prison there's nothing I'm gonna
say that's going to get anybody in
trouble here and I have the retired ATF
agent that did my case that I'm very
very good friends with and he goes come
on and I go yeah and I go so you can get
a whole version from his side and he
goes I love it he goes after the New
Year I'm gonna hook you up with my team
from Seven Buck oh Frankie over there
and he goes into we're gonna start this
journey and he says but uh be patient
because something like this we we have
to tell it respectfully we have to tell
it you know the right way and you know
we just can't let anybody grab this
story because they want to glamorize the
violence but that's not where you're at
that's right we're going to do this the
right way and I said okay I trust you we
know we don't know each other like that
but I trust you I always heard he was a
man of his word and you told me that
later in life but you know so then me
and Frankie got together what was it
Frankie
2018 we started the first okay 2018.
we started telling the story
me Bayless to Frankie you know we're
he's you know putting the a team
together and of course Billy Corbin
right Cocaine Cowboy squirt group or
screw balls one of the best rights best
yeah and uh big billy Corbin fan of
everything he does and now
I don't meet you yet
but I know you're said soon to be
brother-in-law and you marry Aaron sits
with her sister Jackie the notorious
angle family I know your father-in-law
big Mark comes a dear friend of mine
right one of the toughest guys I think
we could say we know I'm gonna go there
man Mark so I'm in Pittsburgh I'm
fellowshipping and hanging out with big
Mark and everything like that you're in
town and they bring you to Jim mannion's
bodybuilding show I get to meet you
because I'm a big fan you know of all
the things I loved what you did in my
favorite movie shot caller love that
movie right of course the joint the
penitentiary right you know and uh my
favorite one right so then you come come
to the bodybuilding show I get you guys
in sitting VIP you're sitting next to me
I remember how amazed you were with the
size of the dudes you're like Mel look
at the sizes of these guys right like
you were really like wow man that was
the first time you were ever that get me
that close to a stage
and we started talking and you're like
hey congratulations on this on this
thing that that DJ's doing for you and
you go you're in good hands man he's a
solid brother he's a man of his word and
you are in the best hands and I go John
thank you man it means the world coming
from you you know and uh me and you were
just talking about that right no idea of
anything right so we take a picture
together you leave
six seven eight months later you know
under a year or whatever the time would
be wasn't long
DJ calls me up and he says hey he goes I
I gotta run something by you I got this
idea
and he said uh but I want you to be
comfortable with he always says that you
know I want you to be comfortable with
it you know and he goes I got The
Perfect Dude to play you in the scripted
series I said okay and I'm with little
melon in the in in our in our truck you
know where I got him on speaker
and uh and he goes okay he goes man this
guy's a good brother he goes he's super
intelligent he can get in here and help
produce and help run everything his mind
is amazing he's going into this his
Spiel he goes he can play the old
jewelry you get gritty because he could
play that that young you and he goes and
he can play where you're at now this
dude is is the guy that I want but I
want you to be comfortable so it was
like a five minute thing right as he's
going through with this right and I said
okay who and he goes I did a movie with
him now he doesn't even tell me your
name because I did a movie with him and
he goes and uh and uh his name's John
Bernthal and I go I forget a little
melon I start laughing and he goes are
you okay with that nice I'm gonna blow
your mind I said I know you don't see a
lot of social media being the I call him
the busiest guy in the world right
you didn't see a pist a picture I posted
about six eight nine months ago whenever
it was with with John did you he goes no
so you know him I said yeah and here's
how I know him you know how I'm partners
in the hormone replacement company Core
Medical and he goes yeah I said my
partner Sid and John are soon to be
brother-in-laws he goes wow and I'm
going to blow your mind again your boy
Kurt Angle because they're you know I
know DJ loves Kurt I go John married his
niece Aaron and Sid's about ready to
marry his other niece the sister Jackie
and he goes wow bro because you should
have stopped me five minutes ago we
started laughing and he goes look at how
that is I go it can't be more organic
than that yeah man right nobody you
didn't even know this he's picking you
for the love you know you know I'll tell
you what DJ thinks to you and when you I
know what you think of DJ and everything
like that and here we are and here's the
story now and uh so I see I said okay
and he goes you you know I said he goes
you want to reach out to John and then
we talked to Frankie we got Frankie on
the phone and I said I'd love to reach
out to John and he goes but we're gonna
do it the professional way too through
your agent and everything like that so I
called Sid because I'd never your number
even then you know we met and we we
bonded and you know and you went your
way and I went my way and I called Sid
and I go hey man here's the deal I said
we just got this call and he goes all
right I'm gonna call Johnny go but you
got it they want to do it from the team
respectfully too you know so then you
knew but then you got the call and you
were all in right bro and jumped in and
and uh and you know then we started the
journey so it was just so so cool how or
organically and I said the hand of God
how he has everything in the plan
because listen
Mel Chansey that grew up the way I grew
up and you know running the club stuff
I'm not putting Dwayne Johnson Billy
Corbin John Bernthal because
um got some mystical Powers right that's
I say the the way things are supposed to
be the hand of God and here we are you
know and and the journey has been
amazing because what's it it's got to be
every bit of two three years Frankie
right that that John has been part of
this right every bit of you know I think
it was only a little bit after a year
when this happened so you've been on a
while like with your hands involved in
it and you know even though it's not
there yet but you're a big part of
everything we're doing but but you know
it's it's from the beginning you felt it
you felt you know I think it always
comes down to to intention you know come
so what do you what are you really
trying to do why are you trying to tell
these stories why are you trying to have
these conversations you know and and and
uh there's nobody in this business that
uh I I believe in as much Integrity wise
as as as Dwayne you know it's not just
his work ethic or it's just that you
know is is talent and his personality
and and what he's about what he puts out
there in the world is uh that's what I'm
going to do now a journey of it that
we're all doing we're also spending the
time together and here we are and I'm
out with you doing the podcast and uh we
got some familiar faces back here and uh
yeah we do it's been a long time man I
haven't been in California since 97 you
know so things have really changed out
here for me and you know and I don't
think a California is the old days you
know yeah the only reason I came out
here in the 90s was to see the fellas
who do what I was doing yeah but um and
then that stopped and I don't come out
here we have bodybuilding shows out here
and I run all that but you know they got
their own chairman out here and it's
it's pretty good so I always stay East
in Midwest and all that stuff like that
we got guys taking care of it out here
everything's a brings up memories to me
I think of everything you know and and
and and you know man that the the one
common thing is like you know when you
were talking about the things and and
it's funny because
you know now now George is here and yeah
and Lou's here and you asked me about a
guy that who who I looked up to and
that's it and I said there was multiple
people I walked up to right not just one
I was young yeah you know and George's
son when he was alive God Rest the soul
I I was friends with him I was young he
was younger than me and uh but I looked
up to them guys there was very good
leader figures in that club that were
you know from a lot of different spots
that I looked up to you know being that
young guy I didn't there wasn't a
Playbook like I always say they didn't
give me a Playbook and this is how you
got to be you're looking up to people
that have been around a long time right
and I was that guy in the room watching
everybody doing their things and
learning from them I wanted to learn
just like when I got in the bodybuilding
just like what you enacting you put
everything to learn that dude that's
right everything and I was putting
everything to watch how these guys were
successful in running it you can't go do
this through life because somebody's
gonna answer the call right right so you
have to be diplomatic you have to be
that good guy that's in charge I don't
like to say leader but that good person
that's in charge that knows how to
handle everything and I had multiple
people that I looked up to and and
George being one of them you know so you
know and I haven't seen him in so many
so many years because you know it's I
got out of the club and you know George
was still in the club you know I quit
the club in 2000 four and then you know
he was still on his journey with it and
then you know he's out and you know it's
like it's like this
when you leave you know
even if you leave in in good uh people
don't like that right some people just
they're gonna stay what they're doing
but I'm always the type of guy like if I
can't give a hundred percent I'm not
gonna stay there
it's not for me no more I know when it's
time to cut and run you know and it just
wasn't there for me no more you know
um
so you don't really talk to the old guys
anymore you know and then you know
things change and they get mad at you
and you're out bad and you know how how
it goes right you've heard the story so
you know you don't get to see anybody
but I was able to follow George on
social media and see it you know people
a lot of people ask me because they know
I was around them them days you know and
I always say like George was the real
deal he was a man of his word you didn't
get no no [__] with George he
treated everybody with respect and the
same from the club to not the club he
dealt with a lot of things with us with
the outlaw stuff too and I remember a
time I'm gonna say a time because George
just remembered coming up here you
remember I struck my memory
when we sat down with the Outlaws and we
talked about this already on that peace
deal and I said there was you know five
six guys from each side
we came to San Francisco
okay and they came to to California to
sit down because they knew they had
everybody's word that this was a
peacetime let's sit down and talk and
put the differences aside
so I came in the room in this in San
Francisco and George was there me George
and five six other guys I don't know
exactly who but I sat in a chair at the
end of the table and the outlaw
leadership wasn't there yet they were
coming and walking into one of our
clubhouses big big move for them you
know you never know it's you know takes
a lot of guts to do that you know
unarmed and we're all you know we're all
they're taking our word
and one of the one of the members that
was sitting there and he goes ah hey
Road you better not sit there man you
know you're good you're going to be too
intimidating when these guys sit here
and George says leave him sit where he
wants right like they're coming here
right we sat on the table and we all
were good and we sat down and we made
some rules like let's follow these rules
let's practice The Good Neighbor policy
and everything so he George was involved
in that you know and that's you know
right after that that's when I told you
I went to prison shortly after that you
know and uh but uh you know the memories
are you know so he's one of the guys you
know that was that that that paved the
path for us young youngsters you know
and uh and then I used to like coming
off the Ventura because I liked
California I used to come to San Jose a
lot and I was real tight with a guy
that's passed on by the name of Steve
tossen and uh
um you know that's where they where they
get the Mr 187 he's the original Steve's
the dude who who kind of that was his
nickname you know and he gave me that
nickname in the Tet allowed me to get
the tattoo on my wrist that came from
Steve that was like a gift from him for
you to be thank you yeah yeah that was
his thing that was Steve's you know he's
the original you know and Steve was an
amazing boxer and an amazing member and
stuff and passed away right so um I used
to come out here all the time but I
would like the Ventura crew because
there's a lot of youngsters over there I
was a Youngster at the time these guys
were much older than me you know I was
24 25 years old and stuff you know a lot
of the guys were 10 12 years 15 years
older than me been around a long time so
they had the young young crew in Ventura
and California was great especially back
in them times because there wasn't
they didn't have that controversy going
on it was it was peaceful time so we
would I would get out of Chicago and
come down here and be like ah it's sunny
it's great out here chicks you know
everything's great you know so you want
to get out of the turmoil you don't want
to go from one war zone to the next
right like I would go to New York and
stuff and hang out with the guys but
they had their own skirmishes going on
with different clubs middle of Wars
there it would be the pagans and all
that that's a popular one going on let's
go west let's go hang out in Sony
California for a while you know it was
before the crazy craziness you know it
was in between the what they did in the
80s and that like Gap time you know so
it was cool out here so you know when
you said come on come on out I said
let's go we were originally going to try
to do this in Florida
and with your schedule and everything we
said let's you know yeah man pretty cool
uh before you know I wanted to see if
maybe uh George and Lou want to sit down
for a minute but before we get the guys
in pee break yeah
yeah man let's uh let's go
foreign
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's John Bam
Bam the dog uh first on behalf of both
of us and everybody from the real ones
team I just want to sincerely thank you
guys for for tuning in the folks that I
bring on the show they're family to me
and uh being able to tell their stories
and bringing you into their world
something I'm I'm just super proud of
and again grateful that you guys tune in
we've decided we want to take things
just a step further it's a patreon
community and basically what that means
is if you become part of this community
look I already board Bam Bam if you want
to become a part of this community
you're going to be able to hear episodes
early and all that ad free and all that
good stuff but there's all this behind
the scenes footage all this stuff that
we've shot that really brings you into
the folks that we've had on the show
really brings you into their world live
chats with me and the folks that I bring
on the show to talk about their world
talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
year was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and given the mic to them so the
fact that you guys tuned in means the
world anyways again thank you be good to
each other out there rock and roll